Yes.
What's up
sturgeon?
Mother Falcons in.
Dude,
you've been on a ride.
So last time I talked to you,
when was the last time I talked to you?
Wasn't that long ago?
No,
last time you'd been here here.
Things kind of just something wonky.
It was boomi almost a really good show.
I'm wrong with that.
Somehow with the headphones might be
just me.
Might fucking weed.
Well you ever.
Yeah that sounds better.
Thank you.
Which Jamie some fucking effects on that
bitch.
He didn't touch anything.
He was just asking because if February.
So um,
uh,
yeah,
I mean you're blowing the fuck up dude.
I have to get this out of the way before
we even start talking.
Got It.
It's fascinating to watch was a because
well it's always fascinating to watch
someone who you think is very talented.
Get recognized and I thank you.
Very talented.
So then,
and then becoming friends with you,
it's interesting to talk to you and to
see what it's like.
See me process it all the time.
Probably have some interesting insight I
would imagine.
Yeah,
I guess so.
For me,
it was a slow,
one was a slow burn,
took a long time and a lot of different
shows till it started getting really
weird.
It was pretty manageable news radio.
Was that.
How long were you out here before that
happened?
I came out here for a show right before
that I was on another show called
hardball.
There's this baseball show,
so that was like,
uh,
maybe like six months before news radio,
so it wasn't very long.
I came out here specifically for that
hardball show.
One of the things just sort of
opportunities turned into other things,
you know,
the ebbs and flows and comes and goes.
But uh,
the news radio fame was nonexistent.
Like nobody ever recognized me.
Everyone.
But you're getting recognized now.
Not Too much man in specific towns where
we do better.
Yeah.
But it's mostly,
you know,
99 percent of the time.
People were really cool.
Yeah.
Isn't that the fact?
Yeah,
that's really what's up.
Ninety nine percent of the time.
People really good.
Even the one percent are still cool.
It's just lasts a little too long.
I don't know.
It's the outliers.
Know the extreme cases that aren't,
you know,
the one percent of the one percent that
could be a sign in that in the grand
scheme of things,
I don't feel like I've really blown up
that big,
you know what I mean?
Like it's,
I feel like I've clawed my way to the
beginning as it were.
That's a good way to look at it.
But it's some.
Well,
I mean,
what's the beginning?
What's the,
what's the,
what's the top?
I don't.
I don't know exactly what I do know is
that there's a lot of people that like
will text me.
Dude,
have you heard a surgical simpson?
Holy Shit now
man.
It's A.
Although
I guess transitionally has been in the
last couple of years,
three years,
but I've been doing this my whole life,
um,
to various levels of thanklessness.
But yeah,
a lot of years in Honky tonks and just
dive bars where you were background
noise.
So I am,
now that I'm older,
I think that's been the best part of it
is I'm,
I'm clear and focused enough and have
enough responsibilities in my life to
where I'm not taking it for granted.
Does it make sense 100 percent trying to
like really use it as the opportunity
that is to do something hopefully bigger
than just myself.
So.
Well being a famous singer,
you know,
you,
you affect people and a singer and a
songwriter,
you affect people in a very strange way.
You know,
the,
there's like a,
an intense emotion that's um,
that's connected to a song that really
moves you,
you know,
there's this intense connection.
And so,
um,
it's,
I think for someone like you,
like it's great that you've got all this
life experience.
I think that helps so much,
man.
I think if you're a fucking Justin
Bieber type character,
boy,
you're almost guaranteed to be fucked.
Like that kind of scrutiny.
I don't.
How old was he when that all started?
Baby Panda,
who he is,
but I couldn't tell you a single song,
but yet I know who he is.
Why is that?
Well,
he's famous as famous as fuck,
but yeah,
the poor guy.
I mean.
Well,
yeah,
the poor guy.
Nobody could nobody.
It's easy to judge and sit back and be
like,
oh,
you're such a fuck up.
Like the kid has a very rare and unique
perspective on the life experience.
That kid is doing a splendid job.
A splendid.
He's fucking up just enough fucking up a
little bit,
but you know,
he's fine in comparison to what a normal
person would be with that kind of insane
breach like that.
It was just what,
what it must be like for him to just try
to go through a group of girls.
He just,
he gets attack like dogs.
They will fight for him.
The claw at him.
What the fuck man.
That he's only like 19 or something.
Right.
And is he 19?
That's insane.
It's got to be so hard to,
to keep your shit together and to have a
balanced perspective because there's
only perspective is one of fame.
So you talking about the Honky tonks and
you know,
when you hear last time you talked about
crazy jobs you had,
like you worked on a train,
right?
Yeah.
I mean think about that kind of shit.
Go from that,
that kind of shit to where you are now.
You have an earned perspective,
an earned perspective.
Whereas it's still hard to feel like it.
When you say earned.
My life's pretty,
pretty cool now,
man.
Like I get to go out and make art for a
living and support my family and,
and play music.
Yeah.
No,
it's awesome.
It's kind of dope for sure.
It even even that said,
as long as it took to get here and even
the last three years we toured our asses
off me like going in circles to kind of
build it organically,
you know,
uh,
feel really proud about that because all
I,
no matter what happens up or down,
like,
and I can feel like I accomplished
something with merit,
but it
was,
it beautiful time.
It's a beautiful time for artists,
you know?
So we're definitely in a moment.
Yeah,
right.
For sure.
It seems like a moment with music,
a moment with.
It's definitely a moment with stand up
comedy.
We all talk about it.
It's like the best time ever for standup
I think contribute.
I'm still getting over.
Brian Holtzman,
who was the guy that did the last set
that do that fucking.
I was traumatized.
I was an experienced man.
I can't even tell you because you got
motherfuckers didn't tell me what was
coming to sit.
I'm sitting here thinking like I'm
watching this guy bomb harder than
anything I've ever seen.
Like telling people in the audience to
just start fucking.
And he's like truck couldn't take my
eyes off of it.
It's amazing.
It was awesome.
And then after the study is like,
yeah,
you know,
like,
Holy Shit.
That was all just geodis yeah,
he's genius.
Brian holzman's genius 100 percent.
And he keeps running out of the room
man.
Like literally this takes two were
together,
ran out of the room to get away from
this thing happening.
The vial expression of toxic masculinity
on stage.
Yeah.
Brian does the kinison spot,
which is the last spot of the night.
So the last guy on the comedy store,
most pops the comments?
Yeah.
Last Pot at the comedy store.
It just goes on from like,
I guess he gets on probably somewhere
around 1230,
maybe one inch and then he'll,
he might go til to.
So he's got a long stretch.
He does whatever he wants.
That's why it's the innocence.
How long has he been in this?
But while he's the perfect guy for that
spot and he does it on and off.
He's been there at the store as long as
I have.
He's been there at the store since
[inaudible] 94.
I was,
I met him in [inaudible] 94.
Was it always in that room?
Now?
He does the little room to.
That's where I first met him or first
met him.
He was like this promising up and coming
guy that would go on in the smaller room
and um,
you know,
he was like one of the hot up and coming
guys.
But he always kept like a real job.
But he's,
in my opinion,
he's one of the best comics in the
world.
He just doesn't get a chance to show it
to people.
We've tried to talk about like what
would be the best way to let people know
and I think because he changes his stuff
so much.
I think just putting cameras on him
every night filming these Kennison spots
that he does every Friday and Saturday
night.
I tell everybody if you want to see some
comments to tough one because to,
to make people aware,
you know,
to let them know you kind of have to
almost in a way sort of have to give
away what makes it,
what it.
I don't know man.
It doesn't bother me.
I know,
I know and I think it's fucking genius.
I know he's a great guy and it's.
But I mean we're,
we're,
we're kind of beating around the Bush
here.
He says obviously ridiculously offensive
thing,
but he doesn't really mean
I fucking have always loved that style
of comedy,
you know?
And he's in my opinion and like one of
the best ever at it.
He's a monster.
Just people don't know for whatever,
but they don't know because he never
left.
He stayed at the store and that's a spot
he stayed in la and he always kept a
job.
He always had a job.
He's a meter,
a meter maid at one point.
Had a bunch of jobs like that kind of
will be Koski type guy.
Exactly.
But you know,
you,
you got to do it all for them.
Like someone's got to come along and do
it all for them better.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It was just like,
all right,
let's be casual,
bro Kissed.
But uh,
yeah,
I'm in the studio either man really bug
you.
They fuck with me.
It's just not,
it's not a natural,
uh,
you're,
you're responding to what you're
hearing.
You're close to the,
you know,
it's good for some people because some
people don't realize how goofy it sounds
when everybody talks over everybody.
I'll give you a three people and they
don't have the ear things while you were
talking about before you.
Yeah.
So the fight podcasts we do for people
and we made it mandatory like got to
wear earphones because we were drunk and
stoned and we're talking over each
other.
People with chewing into the mic,
you know,
how bad it sounds,
people eating pickles,
potato chips and pickles into the
fucking microphone and it's just like,
oh my God,
I would get these screaming texts from
people,
stopped chewing into the fucking
microphones.
So we had to,
we had to institute the headphones
policy,
but for a gentle conversational,
it's like yourself.
It's very easy to put those aside.
Are you,
um,
like when you were touring like all
those three years when you were going
crazy and,
and torn like a maniac,
have you settled that down to more
manageable sort of a schedule?
Yeah,
it,
it would have been fine otherwise.
I mean I've always lived out of a bag
really,
you know what I mean?
And,
and wanted to be moving all the time.
So like in that regard is kind of ideal,
but it just,
the timing was a little bittersweet.
Right.
My son was born about a month after the
last record came out of a,
um,
it was home for that.
And then basically three,
three or four days after he was born,
I had to go to Europe for some shows.
And then press started rolling in a word
of mouth and record,
just started selling to,
it's like a movie and my weight and my
wife has a very supportive in our that I
wouldn't have moved to national first
place to do anything without her,
like telling me you can do this,
you know what I mean?
I'd probably still be working for the
railroad.
So,
uh,
when,
when it all kind of came about,
you know,
just basically said,
we didn't,
we didn't come here and like you do
everything up until this point to not be
able to go and because you have to,
now you have to tour,
right?
Um,
so,
uh,
did in other,
you know,
I think missing out what was going on at
home and,
and carrying some sense of guilt maybe
for that,
because even though like in my hair and
my dreams are coming true,
it's providing for my family,
but when we come home after five or six
weeks and then I've got a week at home
before leaving again,
I'm just kind of see.
I was seeing what I was missing and
incremental stages,
you know,
and I think it took a toll on me
emotionally in a way that I wouldn't
have anticipated.
So that's kind of where this record came
from.
I don't go on that kind of tour,
but when I go away just for a few days,
just for four or five days.
Yeah,
it bums me out when you come back home,
this rush of love,
you know,
it's a good way to put it.
It's what it's like.
It's like this new when I come home,
like I just got back from the road.
I was in Boston this weekend.
I come home on Sunday and when your kids
run up to you and jump into your arms
and you're carrying them and talking to
them,
you know,
it's like,
it's very hard to describe for anybody
that doesn't have any children or
doesn't have close friends with
children.
It's very hard to describe.
It's a fucking game changer.
Game Changer.
It changes who you are instantly.
Yeah.
You just different thing.
You're a different perspective on the
world is so different and I don't think
it's mandatory.
I think this is important to say because
man,
I used to bum me the fuck out when
people who were fathers or mothers would
treat you like you were doing something
wrong because you didn't have kids.
There was something wrong with you or
they would tell you that you don't even
know about life until you have kids or
that you know.
Yeah,
it's a perspective enhancer,
but guess what?
A lot of Shit's a purpose.
Perspective.
Enhanced or like you don't have to do
it,
but for me,
because I just hate when people tell
people you know,
that it's like this mandatory aspect of
life.
I think you could absolutely have a
fulfilled life and never procreate.
People shouldn't be appearance,
man.
Yeah,
for sure.
Almost every girl I ever dated stay out
of the business.
That's not true.
They changed to man.
I have a buddy of mine.
His ex girlfriend was crazy just off the
charts crazy.
Just wild girls out of her mind,
drugs and sex and chaos.
She had a kid.
Bam.
Snapped out of it,
eats healthy,
organic.
She's super mom who wasn't about her
anymore.
It also is about a fresh chance to do
something correct and raise a child
would love and and not create someone
like yourself.
It's a,
it's this weird eyeopening thing.
I think for a lot of people when they
realize we're all,
their anger comes from where all the oil
comes from not being raised correctly.
That's a giant part of most people's
lives
is what kind of an interaction you have
with the people that love you and if you
get programmed like real early on,
that love means hitting and screaming
and chaos and yelling and fighting to.
By the time when I was a kid,
man,
I used to look about marriage,
like somebody wanted a serve me plates
of shit for the rest of my life.
Like what?
Like why would you do it?
Because what I grew up with was just
chaos.
I grew up with people yelling at each
other and hitting each other and ah,
fuck this.
And you don't realize.
I think until you have a little baby
that you're watching,
learn and develop and you sort of data
crunching all this shit,
all these events in this child's life
and you're experiencing all this with
them and we're experiencing with them as
this intense bond of,
of,
of love,
but have also have guidance so you have
to guide this little person and so while
I'm doing that and just little moments
and events in my daughters' lives,
little conversations that we have that
make me sort of process how they view
the world and how they think about
things that has made me just so much
more aware of where a lot of my own
weird personality quirks have come from.
It's like looking into your own eyes so
you're seeing,
you know,
everything is instantly recognizable.
It's a.
But yeah,
that's a good one.
How would you say,
you said the seeing their perspective,
but they're just mirroring whatever
you're doing it because they don't hide
things.
Yeah.
They don't hide emotions.
They don't hide thoughts and if you can
open up lines of communication with them
really young and get them constantly
used to talking about feelings and about
thoughts and about why do you get those
feelings?
Like what,
you know,
they'll get jealous of each other.
Why does she get a new and why do you
care?
She has a new tour.
Like why does that bother you if
somebody else has something good and you
see the little brain going,
oh yeah,
because this is like animal fucking
instinct that makes you want to get
upset about something and you're like,
what?
Her friend gave her a tour.
Where's my shit?
You know?
And you gotta like,
Whoa,
whoa.
You were happy until you found out that
something good happened to someone you
love.
That doesn't make any sense.
Now does it be like,
oh yeah,
you could see the little fucking tiny,
tiny brain spinning on her
just starting to talk.
So we'll get there.
But now it's like trip.
We really like playing drums together.
That's awesome.
When he's talking to you,
is it freak you out?
It's happening right now.
Gosh,
it was there for awhile,
there was this little period was like 10
words every day and you don't even know
they're picking them up until they say
them and they'll look,
you know,
look at something and say it and you
know,
you haven't had this lesson yet.
And it's like,
wow,
man,
for someone to express emotions and,
and uh,
or even to see them
at such a young age and understanding
how to manipulate situations.
That's really interesting.
Social dynamic.
You're worried
like a primitive game of chess.
A little primitive child.
Chess,
my daughter was three and we were skiing
and she was packing her stuff up and uh,
she didn't have her helmet or suitcase,
so she had her suitcase closed and then
my wife goes,
hey,
you forgot your pr,
your helmet.
And she goes,
Shit.
She was three when a three year old goes
shit,
like a nice long one.
Just how to say it.
I had a bite my hand to keep from
laughing.
I mean,
I try to encourage like stuff that's
funny as much as possible,
but he can encourage him swearing
because they don't,
they don't have the self control to like
shut it off and they go to school.
You don't want to be the parents.
They teach the kids.
It's where on that,
but it is fine.
It really is the fuck are we doing is
restricting the use of words to
children.
Let's about over to the PC thing.
Oh my God.
It's driving me fucking bananas.
But this one is just fucking crazy.
So it just so crazy.
Why swears
just seemed so strange.
Like doesn't seem to be an issue most
anywhere else in the world.
You Go.
Well,
for adults in business,
I kind of understand that using them
formalities for formalities mean if you
want to know it is a lazy form of
linguistics though mean.
Sure if you're just.
But Hey,
it feels good so.
Well it can be lazy,
but it's like everything else.
I think it's stress related,
honestly.
Man swearing.
I think it really.
I think it comes from anxieties and
stress induced a variable variables.
I remember like in the navy,
it's fuck this,
fuck that,
fuck every other word,
and when I worked at the railroad was
salty language out there image because
you're under this like highly efficient
expectation all the time and there's all
these creative personalities and ideas
bouncing off each other.
He's a little confined spaces and
everybody's just wound tighter advantage
of the string.
It could be used.
Again,
gay always though,
right?
It can also use as like a pause.
Sometimes people use use it in place of
a meter tool.
Well,
you know,
sometimes people don't know what they're
gonna say next and they say,
ah,
but instead they're replacing with fuck
like fucking fucking guy with his
fucking.
I'm fucking sitting there,
right?
I'm fucking talking to us,
you know,
like that kind of.
That's where it gets real lazy.
That's what most people don't even
realize.
Like the weird ticks they have.
I didn't realize how many times I'd say,
you know,
or you know what I mean.
Or,
or like the word like,
like isn't fucking dangerous one because
you could be talking to someone and not
pick it up.
But then once you do pick it up,
you,
it's all here,
it's all you hear like people have that
little and we're roadblock and they have
a blind side.
They didn't see it a blind spot and they
just say like
all the time.
It's terrifying because it might be me.
I definitely have been.
Tommy has got a bad score.
Has got it bad.
He's got it bad.
He's a like a hawk.
He loves the hymns it up a little bit.
But like in that video he did in
Cleveland this weekend.
Did you see that?
I didn't see that.
That's really funny.
Was it him in Hannibal burress?
No,
no,
no.
He was on a news.
Was playing that character.
Yeah.
I did see that.
Our friend Thompson girl was in this
morning show.
He ever do those.
Do you have to do those morning shows?
I don't do.
My career will suffer to some degree
with cause of it,
but man,
I just,
I would,
I would never ask anyone to deal with me
in a situation like that.
So it's best just to know what you are.
Yeah.
And accepted.
Do you get a hard time for not wanting
to do like certain kinds of press?
Do they give you a hard time?
Not really.
I mean,
I think most of the people who have been
working with for awhile now,
they know who they're dealing with.
Um,
and I,
I don't,
I don't mind doing the press honestly.
It's just,
it's a,
at a certain point it becomes I think
counterproductive or even destructive
because it's,
you don't know,
you just repeating things a lot to the
point that you're asked the same
question so many times that without even
realizing you find yourself giving
verbatim answers.
Whereas when you know it's time to stop
talking about it because it's a like,
like I said,
the more I feel like I talk about it,
you sort of denying people their a
better chance to interpret in a way
that's going to make it mean even more
to them in the hero in a way that maybe
I didn't even mean it.
Does the,
your memories become weird to you and
talk about them all the time too.
When you talk about certain things and
you repeat yourself over and over again,
it does.
It almost becomes a script to you,
like the memories get weird.
I realized,
you know,
like I said,
I've been playing music forever,
but all this other stuff was very sudden
transition,
but being a skeptical,
naturally skeptical person and self
aware like you get in these situations
and I sort of realized there's a certain
theatrical to it all,
you know what I mean,
and and then once you get past the
reality of that and then you,
you learn enough about it to know that
you can sit and talk for three hours
literally,
but it's not a representation of what
you talked about.
You can talk about everything under the
sun and they might take one little
sentence that had nothing to do with
anything and an editor decides that that
should be the title of the article that
has now written from some preconceived
stance that you did.
You were unaware of during the
conversation.
You know what I mean?
It's like
word is especially problematic.
Print context
can't print context and it's literally
someone's interpretation.
It's art.
That's interpreting an individual,
so if someone writes a story about you,
it's really art because it's their own
way of flavoring.
This whole interaction they try to do
with colorful descriptives and they try
to use bold adjectives and try to figure
out a way to paint it in the most
entertaining way as well as get some
point across.
So I think sometimes a lot of guys are
also just trying to get you to click on
their website.
Yep.
That true.
But the way to do that is with a good
entertainment.
So it doesn't necessarily have to be an
actual factual representation of who you
are.
Like if someone writes a story about
you,
like what's almost more important is
this art of getting something salacious
is art of writing something,
something that makes you say,
oh,
this guy's wild or this guy's,
you know,
it has to be like this one thing.
Sturgill Simpson first fucked up man
when he was 14,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Like something like first sentence,
like,
Hey Jesus,
what the fuck is this article going?
You know,
not really,
but he would have you believe that you
know,
and the enemy like it starts.
I,
I didn't realize it until it's,
when you meet people on the street and
you realize they have these crazy,
misinformed ideas about who you are and
what you represent and like
what you are.
I mean,
you know those,
those,
a good lesson learned.
Yeah.
That's a good lesson for anybody.
She would just kind of a dork.
And what's that?
It's really just like a dork and you,
but you're like,
this is outlaw tough guy.
Like,
you know,
fucking dirt.
The dirt.
That's what they think.
I don't know.
Some of them,
some of them probably do.
We're always looking for that though,
right?
I think for the outlaw country guy seems
to be the case.
Yeah.
Like that was the shooter had a song
making fun of all these,
like fake outlaws.
They have all that shit to his dad did
well.
His Dad was the real thing.
You know,
it's got to be hard to look at some fake
outlaws with designer scratches in their
genes.
Like they got attacked by a fucking
leopard or some shit.
I mean,
that looks so stupid.
And when your dad is fucking waylon
jennings,
that's got to be even more offensive.
Okay.
Imagine man,
you know,
and they see these guys with a hat that
they just got 15 minutes for.
They went on stage,
someone handed so placed it perfectly
and someone's doing their hair and
checking in and making sure everything's
good.
Then they send them out there to be an
outlaw
sober on adderall.
Probably Beta blockers.
It's something that I couldn't,
I couldn't possibly describe to you how
little I pay attention to it.
Yeah.
To cut to a country or to music in
general country.
But even anymore I don't really listen
to module one on
you.
Are you buddies with that Guy Jason?
Who is bill?
Yeah,
that's the right way to say it dude.
I just got into him a couple of weeks
ago.
Genius.
Fantastic.
I listened to
that.
Uh,
his most recent album,
like the entire time I was in Mexico,
I was in Mexico for like a week or just
list him the entire time.
Yeah.
We use a jason please.
Some shows together.
Good dude man.
Good,
good.
You should have him on a podcast.
I would love to.
Interesting.
Seems a smart dude.
Great writer.
Oh yeah,
he's Kinda the guy.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I mean the lyrics credible,
intense.
Just so really well structured too.
That's the other thing about this job
is,
you know,
you meet people that you hit it off with
but you never hang out because you're
never at home.
So we've was trying for like two years
to take our wives.
It's one of the other.
You either on tour or somebody back or.
I know exactly what it's like.
I know exactly what it's like a
comedian's.
We worked together a lot.
That's how we do it.
We also worked together at the store.
That's why the store is like a great
base.
It's like home base,
so everybody goes to the store so we
meet each other in the store during the
weeknights and then a lot of times on
the weekends we'll work together.
So like if we do big theater shows,
especially
you think you're down there,
the store,
I'm at least to always at least two.
Just working.
Yeah,
it depends on how many nights I'm in
town,
you know,
but it's,
it's convenient for me because my spots
are always after 10 so my kids are
already asleep so I can,
I can jet out after I put them to bed,
I can get,
you know,
they go to bed at like eight.
So I'm gone.
You know,
it's perfect.
And it's also like for,
for anybody who does the road a lot,
it's a nice wake up call,
you know,
like you just see these animals going up
in there.
You know Chris rock show up working on
his Oscars.
He showed up that Saturday night.
We.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
Chappelle shows up all the time.
Louis shows up all the time.
Bill burrs there all the time.
I mean just all the assessment up and
testing out new stuff or are keeping
their chops up,
chat,
testing out new stuff.
All the above.
Just working,
you know,
it's like they're at everyone's act as
sort of like a work of progress,
you know,
and when you're close to them and you
watch it from,
they'd be like,
like Joey Diaz who I think is the
funniest guy of all time.
He's the funniest guy ever.
Never,
never laughed harder than watching him.
But I watch his bits,
uh,
watch them develop like a because I'm
working with them all the time.
That's some of the more interesting
things about.
One of the more interesting things about
being friends with a lot of comedians is
watching all the different styles of
creation,
how they do it,
how they piece it together.
It's just like songwriting.
There's like,
there's no right way to do it.
Yeah Man,
I tell you what,
just to,
I've only,
you know,
I'm just now getting to spend any time
out here.
Uh,
but there's something about that world
just a couple of times I've gone and
I've spent time in that place.
It's a totally different head space than
anything I'm used to or accustomed to.
And you can see there's definitely a
sense of community.
Oh yeah,
there was a,
a palatable underlying darkness.
Oh yeah.
To at all.
But I think what I liked the most about
it is there's no area,
you know,
for all in all,
everybody seems to be pretty black and
white and like real as fuck,
you know,
you can get away with some ridiculous
shit on that stage two because it's just
the way it's always been like,
like holtzman without giving any of his
set away.
Some of the things that he was saying,
are you like Jesus fucking Christ?
Oh Dude,
I was.
I mean I know you're enjoying that
because also they're just like,
oh shit.
He was particularly on fire that night
too,
like the screaming at people and so what
happens when somebody gets up and just
jumps on the stage and goes for him?
Because it happened before his
girlfriend.
I was just like,
what is happening?
Holy Shit.
That was intense.
But the people were laughing,
but people have attacked him.
Really?
Yeah.
Martin Lawrence,
his bodyguard.
Ego Self.
I mean I wasn't there.
I missed the festivities,
but from what I understand,
Martin Lawrence was in the audience and
him and Holtzman like we're going back
and forth and Holtzman went over to the
table to point out that it was actually
Martin Lawrence that he was,
there was,
he was being heckled by Martins
bodyguard,
gets up,
punched him in the head and knocked him
out.
That was one time I heard,
but there was some other stuff too.
Damn.
One time he took a fucking an ashtray.
And Ari was talking about this the other
day.
The comedy store,
um,
especially like in the early days had
these thick fucking glass ashtrays,
old school school for Ashtrays.
I'm sure many people got murdered with
one of those fucking things.
Holtzman was talking about Charlie's
angels and how angry he was that anybody
really believes how a woman could kick
all those meds.
I take already grabs that ashtray.
Oh,
fucking crusher had he throws the
Astraea at the table and shatters his
fucking ass.
Trey.
Holy Fuck.
Yeah.
It's like,
whoa.
He blew an ash tray up in the room.
I mean,
glass flying all over the fucking place.
he really,
through this ashtray down on this table
and shattered it.
It was a small crowd,
but someone easily could've got hit with
a honker glass that probably that class
probably still on that ground.
He definitely could probably find the
sharp dude,
but he's going for it.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
it's one of those things we were talking
about,
like there's,
there's a.
When you're writing a song,
I guess it's probably similar to where
you are creating this narrative.
You,
you're,
you're being a separate person maybe
than you are in real life and you're
creating it and you're,
you're seeing it from that person's
perspective.
But when a guy like holtzman is doing
that on stage,
he's doing something similar,
but because it's just talking,
people don't accept it as not his
opinion.
You know,
they,
they think that he's just a fucking
asshole and a misogynist and the this
and the that.
And it's not just like he's a character
in a movie that's playing and asshole.
That's happened to be hilarious.
Which we accept with no reservation too
weird,
right?
It's A.
I don't know.
I was just sitting there,
we're really after the fact and then
looking back on what I just seen how
when he's in the moment of playing the
frustrated,
you know,
like you have such,
like what's the fucking,
what's the point?
And I was like,
but it's so he was just so in that it
has to make me feel like a part big part
of.
It's coming from a real place to,
you know.
Oh yeah.
It's just.
I mean he's not carrying that around
with them all the time,
but that's definitely coming from a real
place.
He has been about Hillary.
I can't give it away in a way.
Yeah,
for sure.
Definitely.
But he's like,
he's a very smart guy.
Obviously he's legitimately frustrated
at the world around him.
You know who isn't,
but if you're not,
then you're not paying attention.
It's that simple.
In this day and age,
look you.
What we all should try to do,
and I know you agree,
is try to be as harmonious as you can in
your life,
in your personal life and your
friendships harmonious as he can.
The problem today is that in this day
and age,
we have access to all the stories,
all the stores everywhere.
There's too many of us.
That's too much data to crunch.
You're only going to get the shitty ones
because it's shitty ones.
The ones that going to hear about
because those are the ones,
you know,
Isis cuts baby's head off.
Holy Shit.
The babies scare me,
man.
Don't worry about isis and things like
that.
Worry more about natural disasters will
weirdest,
weirdest to say that whatever we talk,
when I get hung up on fault lines and
uh,
you know,
the inevitable,
but my wife makes fun of me about it.
But no,
I mean,
I guess a shouldn't be worried about
isis.
But um,
um,
I mean hell,
these Neo Nazi
been
perspective Zionist group scare me more
than Isis.
You know,
like people like the homegrown ones.
This ones actually here in our country
that the Oregon guys a high I don't
want.
Well I don't,
man.
I watched about two minutes of that and
was just like,
I can't even look at this.
We still never found out who called
them.
Y'All Qaeda,
we believe someone on the show named
them yell,
Kil Kinda.
It was either that or was it a comic
that we named them?
I saw it a lot of times on Google,
so I don't know where it started,
but might not have even started there.
Then the person who said it might've
heard it first.
Either way,
what a fucking great name.
Y'All Qaeda.
I fuckin love that name.
How did,
what did,
what did.
I mean?
I honestly did step away,
wouldn't end up happening with all the
um,
one guy got shot and killed and then
there was uh,
some guys turned themselves in and uh,
you know,
there was a standoff for a long period
of time had do with grazing
and cattle cattle on,
on public land.
We call it department of land
management.
Dlm is a dlm land.
Is that it?
Bureau land management.
Blm,
that's it.
There's a mountain range and he taught
it would still be on Blm land and a lot
of the hunters for literally 100,
100 year ban on is the Okra,
I think Okra,
mountain range and valley.
And they were getting ready to open it
back up after a hundred years.
So they say,
well,
most people don't have this and their
country.
Most countries don't have a giant swaths
of public land that you can hunt and
fish on.
Right.
That was all because of Teddy Roosevelt.
Teddy Roosevelt faced so much pressure
to not to not do that and to give in to
that,
that he wound up leaving.
Was he a Republican or Democrat?
I feel like the Democrats used to be the
more conservative ones back in the day
and then the Republicans were the more
open minded and liberal.
Then somewhere along the line,
the polar axis is shifted.
That's what I've written.
Read Rather.
Anyway,
Teddy Roosevelt,
he deemed all of this land all over the
country as public land.
And you,
you could never do anything with it.
You can't.
You can't fucking put cities in it.
You can't do shit with it.
This is just public land and this is
land owned by the people of the United
States.
And there's been a lot of like really
shady politicians that have looked at
our debt because the United States has
massive debt and they'd said,
look,
this is one way we can get rid of this
debt.
We can sell some of our public land.
I think Paul Ryan,
that guy that's one of the presidential
guys,
think he bowed out of the presidential
election,
but he was one of the guys that was.
It was one of his proposals and people,
the outdoors people,
people that hike and hunt and fish.
They were going fucking crazy.
Like you can't do this like you can't.
But.
But you look at it on CNN,
it's like one of the most important
things about what makes this country
amazing is some of our natural
resources,
our parks.
Nothing else like it on the planet to
Yosemite.
I mean,
cody,
go to Yosemite if you don't think
there's,
there's some majesty in places in the
world,
like almost like a magic land.
You look at those mountains and you see
a grizzly bear and you see a herd of
Bison.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
like this.
What is this?
This is a wild park.
You can go through this park and you
might get eaten by a grizzly.
Go ahead.
Good luck.
I mean,
you're in the world where people are
fucking coddled and pampered and every
edge is covered by a thick chunk of
nerf.
Shit gets real.
Dude.
You could walk to yellowstone,
to people over the last like five years
had been killed by bears.
It happens more than you think.
Yeah,
man.
My friend was there.
He heard wolves howl.
He said it was the craziest shit.
He said,
we're in Yosemite near here.
You hear it.
I was like,
is it like a coyotes game?
Know
it's a fucking wolf man.
It's different.
Bad,
bad,
bad.
Way To go to Roosevelt and yellowstone.
Have you ever been to the ranger station
that.
I think he's the one that had it built
out there,
but it's this like 20 story,
high cabin.
There was all these weird.
Wouldn't you can go to them?
I've heard of it,
but I never been amazing.
Just a really old,
really old to me over 100 years old with
all the forest rangers.
I think.
I hope I'm getting that right,
lived in it,
but it's pretty much like the coolest
treehouse you'll ever see anywhere on
the planet.
What is big hunting lodge?
Wow.
Check it out.
If you're out there,
imagine those days man,
when they.
They only,
you know,
like we have a pretty clear view from
all the data we've taken in all the
photographs and video and all the
peoples accounts.
We have a clear view of what this
country's like.
You know,
at this point.
Yeah.
We know.
We know about the drive to Vegas from
La.
We know about going up the coast to Sam.
You know what I'm saying?
We don't.
But in the Teddy Roosevelt days stay
where they were still like 50 years into
picture.
Undaunted courage.
Their first pictures were in the late 18
hundreds.
Right.
So the Teddy Roosevelt age.
I mean this motherfucker was,
they barely knew anything.
No the fuck.
Did they.
How?
What year was Roosevelt President?
Early 19 hundreds.
Nine.
So think about that.
They'd only had pictures for like what,
50 or 60 years.
How many pictures of their,
of their,
of yellowstone or of the Colorado
rockies are all the different types of
wildlife you're going to run into about
a wolverine.
You got a photo of a wolverine,
yet I just stumbled across that fucking
thing for the first time going,
Jesus,
what is that?
Fuck,
man.
I was watching this video the other day
with this dude who was driving his
fucking car.
He watched a wolf and a c and a mountain
lion fighting to the death there would
duke it out right in front of him and he
stopped his car and he said they were so
close that he could reach out and touch
the wolf.
And so he's sitting there in his car
while there's wolf and this mount line
or fucking engaged in mortal combat.
I'm cool,
I'm good.
Whatever,
but what a crazy trip that would be to
see that.
And you know,
if you were in the teddy rose,
if I knew they weren't coming through
the windshield.
Yeah,
go see that.
But I mean I'm getting out of the car.
I don't know.
Yeah,
we drove through yellowstone every time.
It never fails if there is a grizzly
citing.
Yeah,
you get there and there's like 20
carloads of people standing out on the
street with their cameras out and
arranger standards saying,
please get back in your car.
You're,
you know,
you're entering the food chain.
The guy was so sardonic about it.
It was just like,
this is amazing.
This is it right here.
This is the video.
This is the wolf
and the,
the mountain lions.
The wolf by the neck.
Wow.
The mountain lion jacked him.
That is
crazy.
Look at the mountain lion winning.
I think I'd rather get eaten by a great
white shark and taken out by a cougar
man because it's going to play with you
like a ball of yarn.
Back it up,
Jamie,
because before that you actually see
them.
Duke it out before the mountain lion
wins.
My uh,
a friend of mine is a guide.
He's a hunting guide in Colorado.
Look at this battle that mountain lion
just clamps down on his neck at Wolf's
trying,
but it ain't working out.
Dude.
The amount line and letting go.
Fuck.
Did you say that video of the panther,
the lady caught on video running panther
brand by brand by her?
Yeah.
That's in Florida.
Was hiking on antelope island one time
and uh,
just north of Utah and they have this
big buffalo reserve out there.
It's like a public peak probably six
out.
No,
they height in a.
But there's all these free range in
buffalo were on the island,
you know,
it's coming back down the hill.
Me and my buddy and as we were hiking
down a trail,
you know,
about 300 yards down,
I can see there's a couple of buffalo
right on,
right on the trail,
on the footpath.
And we're like,
that's right.
They'll,
they'll be moved on by the time we get
there.
And when we come down the hill,
come around this big boulder and sure
shit,
they're still standing there.
And I,
you know,
my uncle had a farm.
He had cows.
I never been around a damn buffalo.
I don't know the difference in suddenly,
well they'll move.
It's just a big ass cow,
you know,
so we just keep walking towards him
buddy.
He jumps up on a rock and he's just
laughing at me like a dumb ass because
I'm standing there at this point,
this thing is 15 feet in front of God
and it was grazing like sideways was his
hip towards me and he's just eaten.
And finally he looks up and turns his
head and looked at me,
man.
And I realized,
Holy Shit,
that was like the size of a Volkswagen
beetle man.
Oh my God.
He's just looking at me.
I'm thinking this is some dumb shit.
Like,
what am I doing?
You know,
what do I do?
And that's a different buffalo buddy.
That's a water buffalo animals school.
There you go.
Top is the bison.
Yeah.
That's so wild.
He just turns and looks at me and I'm
like,
Oh,
I'm so fucked.
And uh,
I didn't know what else to do.
That thing took one more step forward
towards him.
I don't know what else to do because
we're looking at,
we were making and I just kinda like
took.
I didn't know,
like he's going to charge me.
I'm either running or what.
So I took one more step.
And you just kinda like often and him
and his buddy ran,
but when he started running me like the
whole ground shook and I remember
standing there looking at my friend
thinking like,
that could've been really bad.
Oh yeah,
you could be dead.
No stairs steps.
But there's.
But it's open to the public and out
there all the time is buffalo
everywhere.
So that's.
How's that a winning combination?
I like it.
I do.
I like it way better than I liked the
idea of a zinsser nature.
At your own risk.
I think you should enter nature at your
own risk.
And I think nature should be natural.
You're a big bow hunter,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
We'd
started to talk was a dinner,
but I moved.
Remain his shit.
You know,
you shoot an Arrow and an elks ass and
it doesn't kill it.
You just piss it off and now you're 40
yards away from this thing.
What do you do?
Well,
most importantly,
you got to practice like before,
especially if you're gonna shoot an
Arrow,
you,
I practice every day.
Really?
Every day,
every day I go somewhere and I shoot
arrows.
Something you should probably take
seriously,
you've got to take it so it's not like a
rifle thing.
No.
See a rifle thing is,
it's all just about understanding how to
use the scope and understanding trigger
discipline.
You got to understand how to squeeze the
trigger and not pull it,
but archery involves a lot of weird hand
eye coordination and balance.
There's so many different factors going
on.
There's like a little site that you have
and you have to balance that site out
where the bubble is in the center.
You know the level brutal.
You got to make sure that you're not
torquing your go left or right.
You gotta.
Make sure that the peep peep site though
the the little string hold that you're
looking through lines up and eclipses
perfectly.
Your housing,
you have to make sure that your hand is
completely steady.
You got to make sure you don't flinch at
all when you release the arrow.
There's so much going on.
Any micro movement can add up to several
feet left or right when it gets down
past like 40 and fall.
He was trying to control
your attended.
You know,
target on the moving creature.
Yeah.
Moving creature and you have to make.
You have to be good enough to make an
ethical shot.
Right?
You know,
you have to be good enough to,
you know,
and it's not easy man.
It's not fucking easy.
So that's the most important thing.
It's like there's a lot of guys that
shouldn't be doing it because they're
doing it.
And I was gonna say all that said,
when shit goes wrong in what you do.
Well,
you have to have a plan,
right?
If you,
if you shoot an animal and a charge that
you got to have a tree near you or
something where you can get behind the
tree,
you know,
but you've got to assume that if you hit
an animal with an Arrow,
the last thing wants to do is charge
you.
Unless it's a predator.
Predator's might charge you.
Like if you the real.
There's a real possibility that if you
hit a bear,
although I know people that have hit a
moose,
my friend written Ella got run over by a
moose.
He shot it with a rifle and went to move
in for the final shot of the thing was
much better shape than he thought it was
and it got up and charged him and
knocked him over.
Yeah,
and I seen another guy who shot a moose
with a bow and the most charged them,
but most of the time they want to get
the fuck away from me.
But again,
it's not safe.
It's not supposed to be,
but it's real.
I mean,
if you are hunting an elk and you kill
an elk with a bow and Arrow,
you fucking killed an elk with a bow and
arrow.
It is real.
It is 100 percent.
That is a real elk.
It's a wild fucking animal that doesn't
have any rule book.
There's no.
There is no act break.
There's no commercial time.
It's a.
that's a real 1000 pound wild horse with
a tree growing out of his fucking head
and it's horny.
It's screaming.
This thing that's 10 times bigger than
you is running up a hill with a tree
grown out of his head.
You know,
you got to carry it out of there.
Yeah,
we got to cut it up.
Well,
we,
the out that I shot,
luckily we're close enough to get a
truck nearby.
But uh,
I know guys that have had the camp them
out,
packed them out.
Yeah.
Because you know the smell and
everything.
You're drawing predators at night if you
have to.
There's got to be real careful but
wolves to.
I have a friend of mine who's going to
be on next week,
this Guy John Dudley,
he was in Alberta and they shot an elk
and they got it surrounded by wolves.
The wolves trying to take the elk.
You said it was.
Fuck.
They killed two wolves like they got.
They got charged by wolves.
Yeah.
It got real weird man.
And he said,
and once they had killed two,
um,
this alpha like hung around the edge of
this ridge and looked down at them and
just decided enough was enough and just
went ghost.
And they all disappeared the entire
pack.
But they were around him howling.
He said he'd get here,
look 12 distinctly different howls
around them and they have an elk on the
ground.
Yeah,
and people,
you know,
people say,
oh,
he killed a wolf.
That guy's an asshole.
They kill a lot of wolves up their folks
and you might think that's terrible idea
and that's horrible and it is
if you don't live there,
but if you live there,
fuck.
They have to like,
you don't understand.
Everybody has this idea,
and I talk about this way too much.
I'll stop,
but everybody had this idea of predators
to delete some character in a movie that
knows the script.
They don't man the,
the.
You have to control their fucking
populations.
They just found 19 dead elk at these
wolves killed in Wyoming.
They just left them there.
They just want our slaughter fest.
They snuck into this pack of like some
of those elpacs in Wyoming.
You'll get like a hundred elk now.
They're in its immense.
These huge,
huge packs of elk.
What'd you call it?
What would you call my herd?
Herd of elk.
And so this wolf pack jumped in there.
Look at,
look at all the elk.
They killed 19 elk and they didn't need
any of them.
These kills killed them.
Yeah.
You know,
like you said,
unless you live there,
it's hard to have an opinion one way or
another.
Everybody that has an opinion and it's
all.
I mean,
people that have unrealistic opinions
about wolves.
Zoll coming from a beautiful place.
It's coming from a place of light.
They love animals.
They do breed dogs and yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
They have letters,
man.
Nothing's hunting them.
Yeah.
People are going with the Alphas.
Good to breed.
He better fucking read up on history.
Natural his desk.
Not True.
They feel fuck dogs.
Fuck like crazy.
The alphas control most of the.
Yeah,
but it doesn't
mean the other ones don't.
Fuck.
There's a lot of bulbs.
They have.
They just did some recent survey on
wolves in a,
I believe it was Idaho and they were
talking about how many of them there are
like,
whoa.
Like this is kind of.
They're far beyond where they thought
that they needed to be before they would
put them back on the hunting list,
but they don't,
they don't ever want to put them on.
Like what happens is they reintroduced
them in the nineties and before that
they were pretty much wiped out by
cattle ranchers and all these people
throughout the west.
There's very few like wild wolves and
North America.
And so they reintroduced these wolves
from Canada that happened to be larger
by the way.
They're larger wolves and the wolves
that were naturally here.
What did the native Americans do?
Both the wolf population.
Well,
uh,
they didn't.
They mean they,
they killed them certainly because they,
they used to use their skin's a sneak up
on bison actually.
Here's a crazy fucking famous painting
and iconic iconic painting of these,
uh,
American Indians with a wolf costume on,
like they have a covering their body and
they're crawling with a bow and Arrow up
to these bison because bison weren't
scared of wolves really hardcore shaking
your head seriously.
Yeah.
Bisons don't.
That's one of the reasons why there were
so many of them.
No other animals really had a very
difficult time taking them out.
Look at this.
There's the picture.
That's like an icon.
That's exactly how it went and looked at
me.
Or is there
going to be bone chilling?
How did that feel?
Like staring that thing down,
man.
I froze.
I literally froze because I just
started.
Didn't know what to do.
Could be the end of your themes you're
standing relating to realize I'm,
I've just put myself on a horrendously
bad situation.
The amount of force they could generate.
You can't even resist it.
There's nothing you could do.
You're just completely helpless.
Like there's literally nothing you could
do.
They run faster than you and there,
you know,
that's a 1500 to 2000 pound animal.
The Indians snuck up on him like that.
And um,
my friend Steve Rinella and not Steven
Rinella,
remy warrant.
He has this television show called Apex
Predator.
And um,
they did all these different episodes on
the ways different animals hunt their
prey and see if he could recreate it.
And that's one of the things that he
did.
He took a wolf skin and put it on him
and crawled up to these buffalo and got
like right inside them.
Yeah,
but they're afraid of us.
Well,
they're afraid of people because of bang
sticks.
True to the.
I was saying earlier,
I forgot what I was talking about for a
second,
but a friend of mine as a guide in
Colorado and they found these mountain
lion tracks like all these mountain lion
tracks and then elk tracks and then the
mountain lion tracks and the elk tracks
together and then there's a space of
like several hundred yards,
whether it was just elk tracks and so
they followed that elk track and they
found a mountain lion on top of the elk
killing it.
His fucking giant elk,
like thousand pound elk.
He said it was a huge six by six,
so you're talking about it in a mature
animal and this mountain lion.
I was like,
fuck it,
I'm going for it.
And he jumped on this thing and clamped
a whole of its back and then brought it
down the mountain line weight 150
pounds.
So it took out this thousand plus pound
elk by jumping on his back and biting
its neck.
You guys get them down in the valley and
allies?
Yeah.
Encroaching killed a Koala bear at the
zoo the other day.
Yeah.
Now are taking it seriously.
They're like,
how the fuck did it get in?
It's got a 12 foot high fence.
There's razor wire on the top panel.
Sneaky as cat,
man.
Come on.
It's so that little fucker that you
walk.
And it was like [inaudible].
I know,
but he climbed over barbed wire.
That's hardcore.
Dude.
That's hard.
As fucking court gets
12 foot high fence barbed wire at the
top was like,
hmm,
good try.
Good try.
He probably got caught up a bit,
but whatever.
He's a mountain lion.
They probably hear like that to in 150
pound cat.
Yeah.
Like if you're riding your bike one day,
one of those things falls over tree on
your head.
It's going to God with these big old
saber teeth and like take you to the
ground and fucking play with you for
awhile.
It's not just going to kill you.
You know?
It's gonna,
it's gonna miss with the size of that
fucker.
That's the one that lives up to the
Hollywood hills.
That's the one that they think killed
the Koala bear.
That's a lion.
A lion.
I mean,
that's like a lion in Africa.
Lion.
Look the fucking forearms on that.
Like those forums.
It would be awful.
That isn't Stetson.
Insane amount of power.
That thing was have.
And they say that pound for pound.
They're one of the strongest cats on my
shoulders and arms.
My Gut,
I'll tell you right now for Bobcat,
tries to fuck with me.
I'll fuck up a bobcat.
I'm pretty,
pretty confident I'll kick a bobcat's
ass,
but it still wouldn't be fun.
No,
I'm kidding man.
Look,
I have cats and I have to wash them.
And uh,
my,
my daughter is allergic to cats and the
way we,
the only way we communicate is we have
to shave them.
So they get a buzz cut like a lion's cut
and washed them.
And it makes a giant difference in how
much damage are they leave.
They leave because they're both like
really fluffy cats.
They would leave cat hair everywhere,
but so this solution made a bit,
but I have to fucking hold onto these
little fuckers,
why they get shaved and man,
even though like they love me and that,
you know,
when they want to go man,
they want to go and you realize like how
difficult they are to controls Agila
yeah.
That fucking boot.
They twist and contort fucking to kick
it off yet.
And it,
this big long sinewy
relaxed muscles that all of a sudden
you're like,
Holy Shit,
you're actually a little bodybuilder.
Okay.
You're just so lucky.
We're so much bigger than them.
But with a mountain lion as a Bobcat,
I'm gonna.
Come,
come get some bobcat.
I'll fuck you up,
bitch.
It'd probably be terrified.
That was a cute one.
That's a links though.
I don't think that's a bobcat.
Those,
uh,
there's.
See those weird links is they have in
Canada.
Those white never been to Canada,
man.
No,
actually it's not true.
I've been to Canada.
I've just never been up to the part of
Canada that I'd really like to see.
They have these weird cats,
man.
They don't even look real.
They look like a star wars cat.
It's called a lynx lynx and they have
these crazy big paws with [inaudible]
serious.
Look at that weird ears.
Yeah,
come on man.
That's like an animal.
Go some Turkish delight.
Yeah.
Look at that.
That doesn't even look real.
Look at that cat.
Tell me.
That looks real.
That looks like something from some
weird movie.
Like the proportions.
I go back to Jamie.
They'll get the proportions of its body.
It's so odd.
Giant feet long as big legs.
Just so weird.
Body man.
And that thing is just up there earning
just earning.
Just out there hustling everyday jacket
shit with its face.
Like what does it hunt and Canada I
guess everything.
I'm sure.
Small things.
I don't think they get that big.
I mean if I had to guess,
I would say links probably only gets to
be like 50 pounds.
See what it see how big they get.
See if I'm right.
I don't think they get much bigger than
that,
but I think they,
they probably eat.
I'm 24 pounds.
Okay.
I think they probably eat like rabbits
and squirrels or Fonz.
They'll definitely eat fonz.
We found this fucked up video of this
Martin,
uh,
Martin chasing a rabbit.
You know,
what a Martin is,
what was the play it for him?
Jamie Martin.
Martin is an animal that I always
associated with for because of those
Alaska shows,
you know,
those shows where the dudes are living
up in Alaska.
There's one called mountain men and this
guy runs a food trap line and one of the
things that he trapped is Martin Martin.
It's like a little badger and it's
chasing after a rabbit.
So the little black thing and the back
is the PA is the Martin and this is a
literally a run for life.
Look at this rabbit is going fuck,
fuck.
And the Martins hustling behind him.
He was moving.
Fuck you at is.
And this is like a crazy sprint.
I mean they're both sprinting.
It's like how long can they do it for?
And the Martin just is relentless and
these people are filming this for their
fucking car.
Following them behind them on the road.
And uh,
the Martin just finally the rabbit
starts trying to veer off the road and
he gets into the sick shit and the
Martin closes the distance.
But look at the drama here.
It runs better on the Hong Bitch.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And what's crazy is they're the same
size.
In fact,
the Martin is smaller.
The rabbit look at the difference things
mean as shit.
Oh yeah man.
I mean he just carried it up by its
face.
That's jumping.
He,
he's like,
he hit a nitro button or something,
but he knew the end was near.
It was cool.
Yeah.
Imagine if you are download rabbit hole
on this thought with a dude to the death
with your faces,
right?
You're good.
You killed them with your face and then
dragged him up a hill with your face all
in the course of 15 seconds from the
time that Martin got ahold of that
rabbit,
that rabbit is dead as fuck.
And he was carrying away in 15 seconds
with this phase.
No.
One of my good buddies is a radiology
technician and he must,
he sees all kinds of horrible shit
happening to people every day.
You know what I mean?
That's why I'm thankful.
I just have to get up and try to sing in
pitch ever to make money.
He said the worst thing he ever told me
was a,
there was a guy who was driving along on
his way to work.
One morning he hit a deer,
the deer,
the body split in half and the ass end
of the deer came up over the hood and
through his windshield.
And I was just intestines and blood and
shit and guts everywhere.
All literally like the glass room.
And she'll cut his face all up.
So now he's got all this shit down in
the blood and in his face.
Uh,
so they bring this guy.
And so he came in and was like,
went through the windshield and laid
down in this creek bed.
Like after he hits the deer and lay
there.
And while I was like laying in the damn
creek bed,
raccoons came and snacked on his fucking
face.
So then when these guided of living,
but I mean between all the bacteria.
So he got jacked.
Yeah,
hit a deer.
All that shit happened and I guess he
liked came out of the truck and then
laid down in this ditch until they found
him like,
you know,
however many hours later.
And while he was laying there
unconscious wild woodland creatures had
came and eaten the open dude had a bad
day.
How much of his face got bitten off?
Oh Man,
I'll,
I'll.
Patrick said it was not pretty holy fuck
man.
And the donor didn't actually live.
Oh God.
You know,
I don't know that I'd want to survive
something like that or maybe you do.
I always want to survive.
But
yeah,
you always want to survive.
You just want to survive just to kill as
many fucking raccoon can be.
Like the best raccoon hunter ever.
That day on the,
a raccoon serial killer.
Just standing in front of trash cans.
A rifle.
Yeah.
I'm glad I don't have to work at a
hospital.
Oh Dude,
I have a buddy was an emt.
Tell me some stories.
The craziest stories.
My friend Steve,
he's an ophthalmologist and he did his
residency in Miami during the cocaine
days and he's played.
He's like,
dude,
you don't even fucking nothing to this
day.
This Guy Steve is strapped
everywhere.
He goes,
yeah.
He wears a fucking gun everywhere.
He doesn't play games.
She lives in Arizona and one of the
reasons why he likes Arizona because you
can conceal carry.
It just seemed too much.
He saw too much early on,
you know he,
he told me just every day was just
gunshot to the head.
Gunshot to the head,
gunshot to the head like you're in.
Yeah,
yeah.
How are you going to maintain any kind
of positive outlook and you can't just
get completely burned out.
You get out of it and he got out of it.
When he got out of it,
it was just like this big breath.
I
whoa,
what the fuck that I just experienced,
but now the knowledge that not only was
that a real thing that he was
experiencing on a daily basis,
all that insane violence and all the
gunshots,
all the craziness.
He knows that even if it's not like that
anymore,
like even if people,
there's the cocaine days are Kinda over.
Miami is much more calm.
The violence not as back.
He knows that that is what people are
capable of within his lifetime.
I'm,
you still see this shit all.
I bet you do,
but I think there was a level of it
during the eighties in Miami.
Do you know who billy Corbin is?
The a documentary filmmaker names.
Familiar.
He's got these two great documentaries
called cocaine cowboys.
Cowboys too.
Yeah,
and billy.
He's been on the podcast before talking
about it,
but he did a great job of showing how
insane that time was.
Which one of the things that he talked
about was how one year,
the graduating class of the police
academy,
every single one of them within like a
year was either dead or in jail.
They had been murdered or they were in
jail for corruption.
Like the whole police department was
just massively corrupt.
Everyone was doing cocaine.
There was murders like crazy all left
and right.
All around.
It was just complete chaos.
Yeah.
Who's the little.
One of the guys' names from the
documentary,
the
white dude with the mustache,
that was kind of like a ringleader of it
all.
Yeah.
I think he went to prison and he's out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The guy who flew the planes very.
The money and the yards.
I don't remember his name either,
but I remember the lady Grizelda or
Zelda godmother.
Oh,
the lady.
I think she's still alive,
man.
I mean she might've died recently,
but I think she was alive and free and
Columbia.
She's living in South America for a long
time.
And hiring.
Yeah.
She got out of jail in America and you
know,
if,
if her hitman who was in jail was in the
documentary,
is being honest about how many people
she killed.
Like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Jack.
She launched,
died in 2012.
Ah,
there you go.
So when the second movie was made,
they focused on her and her being
released.
Oh my God.
What a crazy time.
But so my friend Steve,
you just saw all that man.
Just,
he
saw a guy with a light bulb up his ass
for what?
Someone's stuffed a light bulb up their
ass.
You know when those twisty light bulbs
don't like Christmas tree looking,
they put this up my ass.
Big Ass one.
You know?
I mean,
I say it looks like Christmas tree.
I don't mean like a little one that's on
your tree.
I'm talking about several inch long.
Light Bulb was stuffed up.
This dude's ass.
People get bored,
man.
Yeah,
he.
They found everything.
Wine,
champagne,
corks,
all sorts of different objects like
coffee cups and stuff.
Yeah.
You ever heard any stories like that?
I guess it's also probably correlates
with the cocaine days.
They're probably just sticking things in
every hole.
They had
hats off to anybody.
I can work a coffee because you and your
ass so that it was fun seeing all this
stuff like that.
The,
the different layers of society you're
dealing with on a day to day basis and
having to hold a any type of firm belief
in humanity or civilization.
I don't know where a person.
I think
even people that don't see violence like
people maybe that see just a lot of
accidents.
That's got to be spooky.
They say that a lot of women who are
like emt,
I have a hard time settling down and
like having families,
like they get whacked out by it.
Like particularly that might be sexist
to say I don't think it is because uh,
I think that's something that I've heard
female ain't emt talk about just their
own personal experiences,
but that it's so,
so dark.
Like everyday you're seeing broken necks
and broken legs.
It's car accidents and people splattered
on the road and you know,
Uhm,
because grueling after awhile.
So what's like ptsd numbers like
unprofessional,
like that.
I mean,
you got to be having some trauma.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
You know,
um,
there's a certain amount of stress that
I think comes with any kind of job where
you're looking at death a lot.
I mean,
how much ptsd does a doctor have?
Like emergency room doctors,
how much do they just get accustomed to
it?
I think it takes a very special type of
personality,
you know?
I think it also,
it is,
does man.
I think it's really a lot like what we
were talking about when you're taking in
all these stories in the world because
you can manage your own life,
but you're not.
You're.
If you're paying attention to the news,
you're going to get inundated with
stories by the 7 billion people and it's
just too much.
It's just too much data coming at you
and too much of it negative.
I think that's probably the same way
with like an emergency room doctor.
Like it's okay if you see somebody get
hurt once in your life a few times in
your life or,
or maybe even,
you know,
like you,
you can get desensitized.
They're not processing.
Again,
it's just,
it's onto the next case.
You can definitely desensitized.
It doesn't,
it's not.
It doesn't freak you out anymore.
You see a guy whose leg is hanging off
and you know,
I mean,
especially guys who are taking care of
troops,
you know,
or emt.
Oh my God.
People were shooting at you.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I tried to carry them out while bullets
are flying.
It's insanity.
Again.
I'll just try to sing in key math and I
know
we've got it easy.
It's just fascinating how many different
ways to be a person there are.
You know,
how many different different kinds of
lives you can live,
how many different types of experiences
you can have and your reality could be
so much different than somebody else's
reality and you're convinced that your
reality is life and they're convinced
that there is life.
You know,
like what we're talking about with the
wolves.
Like those people that live near those
things that are fucking shitting their
pants when they hear those howls at
night.
My buddy lives in BC and his neighbor's
cow was taken out by wolves.
While they're all watching,
they're all looking out the window
they're going to do.
Can't do shit.
He can go out and start shooting for to
get full and fuck off.
You can go out and start shooting,
but it's dark.
Unless you have pretty nice scope.
I could live up there,
but yeah,
the winters I think would just be.
That's the thing.
They're ruthless,
but anywhere that's.
It's too nice.
You get too many people.
Like we were talking about Los Angeles
is too perfect.
Everyday the weather's perfect,
but because of that you have to bring
carbon monoxide air.
Uh,
you know,
have a.
yesterday it was the first time I'd
ever,
at some point I think we're,
my family was ready for an adventure or
a relocation.
But yeah,
I don't know that I could ever acclimate
no matter how long I was here to
convincing myself that the traffic is
worth it,
worth it.
It doesn't.
You don't have to live here.
See,
that's the beautiful thing about
southern California is you could live in
San Diego,
La Jolla,
like,
which is beautiful and quiet and fucking
picture ask.
You see the ocean's right there.
So pretty.
Like the northern part of the state law
to northern part stays amazing.
I was in Mendocino over by where the
ocean is.
It's like three hours plus maybe four
hours north of San Francisco.
So pretty man soap or the redwood
forest.
We went through the redwood forest,
did all that shit,
was so pretty.
The Monterey once for a meeting with my
booking agency,
the people who live there get it pretty,
pretty well.
That does not suck than uh,
some friends of St Louis Obispo.
That's really,
that's a nice spot to.
Those places are calm,
right?
Really Mellow.
Yeah.
Real mellow.
My Buddy John Lives in San Luis Obispo.
It was about 15 years younger la,
which would seem like a good idea right
now.
Santa Barbara.
Real nice to really
love it there.
I'm going,
I've got a gig there on Friday night,
Santa Barbara.
It's like,
I don't think it's more than 100,000
plus.
People
don't think it's very big.
Man was shooter.
Loves it out here.
He's lived out here.
Well,
well he's crazy.
Shooter shooter lives in the heart of
darkness.
Was An apartment in Los Filez.
He's a crazy man.
He's like,
you know,
he loves it.
Shooters.
Such a character.
I love that guy who just got on a plane.
Oh,
he's the best.
He's also just like such a character,
like who he is as a person.
Know we had him in here and he was
talking about,
about doing meth was like,
Oh yeah,
I've done math night.
Shit.
Like,
come on man,
you ain't done math.
Never tried.
Plank road
trucker.
Craig is a talented guy too.
And I also liked that.
Um,
you know,
you could listen to any one of his
albums and it's like,
oh,
okay.
He's obviously in some totally different
phase in this album.
He's just trying some other shit out.
He's one of them were naturally and
genuinely curious and interested,
interested,
you know,
like when he's listening to you and
asking questions,
he actually means it.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Which is a rare thing in the music
business coming from the sun of royalty.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
his dad was royalty.
I mean there's,
there's a few musical icons that you
look at it and you go,
well that's like in the royal 100,
100 percent.
You know,
Waylon Jennings is in the fucking royal
100.
I mean there's just,
there's just people that are in,
you know,
Chuck Berry's in,
you know what I'm saying?
He's in forever.
Waylon Jennings is in,
he's in,
that's his son,
so for him to be so normal and also be a
musician and not be some Weirdo who
fucking desperately craves attention or
needs validation,
he's a genuine artist and very content.
If anything,
I've seen him use his position to only
try to help other people instead of
himself,
unless the truth man.
Uh,
well his mom was obviously so nice to.
Oh yeah,
she's so nice.
So and,
and really like sharp and smart.
Oh yeah.
Paying attention.
Oh yeah man,
it's cool to talk to him.
It's so weird.
Businessman trying to.
I mean everyone out there,
everyone.
I think that's true.
Everyone that's not like some sort of a
perfect person.
He's trying to do better with their
life,
you know,
trying to improve on whatever you're
doing,
whether it's your job or your business
or whatever.
Whatever your hobby is,
your obsession.
We're all trying to improve on it.
But one of the
weird things about being a musician and
I guess a comic as well,
is that you're doing that in front of
everybody.
You know,
like your developed.
We're all developing as humans,
you know,
but you're also,
you're performing in front of all those
people.
Yeah,
it is.
Uh,
when you,
when you write songs,
I guess you can't ever stop to think,
oh,
I have to sing this,
the restroom,
my life.
You know what I mean?
You could have the crowd you don't know.
Like that's our.
Well,
like for me,
I was,
I don't know,
I liked the song is just a lot of people
really like that sounds bad ass.
I play that song,
that gym almost every time I workout.
That's a bad ass song.
You just do close to.
It was too close to the oil.
Yeah.
It was a laundry list about
my,
my view on laundry lists.
Experienced.
Yeah.
It's just such a great song though.
We'll dig that one back out.
It was Tom,
tom to work it up,
I think in a new way and make it fresh
for us.
I don't know.
For me,
man,
I love the recording process most.
Most of all.
Really.
That's,
that's,
that's where you learn.
If you've improved,
you know,
you're under a microscope,
a get hyperfocused in the studio,
it's a good thing.
Other people get tired or I'd probably
just keep them in there all day,
you know what I mean?
And then,
but it's almost like you're so tied to
this thing in,
in,
in it that by the time it's finished you
just don't even want to think about it
anymore.
You want to,
you gets like,
all right,
well that's done,
right.
You know,
but now you got to work it up and go out
in a live context and,
and play this thing.
Whereas hopefully you've,
you've tried to bare your soul and be as
honest as possible,
but then you're standing in front of a
room every night so you have to block
that part of it out of,
out of your head that like people are
judging you,
you know?
Uh,
and it's also part of it too,
you know,
you're living that life experience out
in real time.
So it's all been really educational and
new for me in terms of figuring out how
to navigate that is artistic away as
possible without
compromising anything.
I guess
I think we all learned from each other
in that way.
You know,
it's got to sell.
Yeah.
Are you going get to do it anymore?
Don't you learn from other musicians in
that way?
Do you see like how other guys are
handling it or how they,
uh,
how it influences their creative
process?
Does it influence you?
Oh,
I mean you definitely noticed traits in
other people that you wish you had more
of or that you could maybe adhere to and
it's,
and it's motivating and,
but like he said,
you know,
it's just about trying to be a better
person.
Yeah.
And uh,
and use whatever outlet this is in order
to hopefully make other people feel good
to,
um,
or to deal with things that maybe they
don't know how to express,
which for me I think is the most
important part of making music.
And so that's what it's always given me
in the past before I was a performer and
I just loved it from a sheer listeners
position,
you know,
offers is a lot of comfort.
And um,
I don't know,
people tell you this after the shows
that you're making an impact on their
life and you know,
some,
uh,
my buddy Jordan said that his friend,
her grandmother's land in her hospital
bed and the last thing she heard,
she played her one of my songs,
like,
you know,
that song,
my voice,
she just said,
wow,
he's got a really pretty voice and she's
like totally relaxed,
you know.
So you hear things like that and it's,
it's easy to get hung up on mechanics or
expectations or pressures or the
industry and all that.
But like it feels like if you just kind
of stepped back and hit pause,
it's easy to remember that anybody doing
this job is very lucky to be able to do
this job.
And for me like,
uh,
I don't think,
I think in a lot of ways the modern
media and industry have sorta not ruined
music,
but it's made it really hard for people
to focus on what is really about,
you know,
it's like life is all of a sudden one
big episode of the voice.
And it's all about the year end lists
and who says this is better than what?
And seen somebody,
the artists better than somebody art and
I just don't think that that's ever like
a healthy thing,
if that makes sense.
Making a competition out of something
that's supposed to make everybody feel
included.
Well it's definitely contrary to what
seems to be your primary focus,
which is making the best music for you,
for your expression.
D,
expressing yourself in the best way you
can and making something that's going to
impact people in a,
in a,
in a way where your thoughts are going
to get across,
they're going to be moved by it.
You can't do that.
If you're thinking about winning awards,
a contract selling lots of or selling or
any of those things like promoting it
business,
you know,
like anytime you,
you not to say that it's impossible.
I mean there is there it's horrible.
Like some people do sell a lot of
records.
Impacting people's lives with great
music is out there.
Music sells.
Yeah.
Period.
It always finds a way.
I mean it's going to sell whether your.
But like,
did you see amy,
amy,
amy winehouse documentary on her
records?
That's what I heard the DAP kings for,
for this new one man.
Just the sound of what they did on those
albums.
Amazing.
She's such as musician.
She was so like her sound,
what she put together was so high.
But to see how the intense pressure of
being,
you know,
amy winehouse in quotes mean she was,
or Justin Bieber or anybody else.
He likes that surrounded by enablers and
kept copacetic all the time and just.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
You know,
you got to do other things man.
You gotta be grounded,
you know,
and I think you've got to go home and
roll around and play with blocks.
Yep.
That's what got to do to get in the pool
with them.
They surf on my back.
I go under water and swim and they try
to stand on me.
It's hard to hold your breath for as
long as it takes for five-year-old.
Stand on your back as you're floating.
But,
but I mean other things as well,
like as far as not just family and loved
ones and friends,
which are definitely important.
But I also think that other disciplines
are important.
Other focuses of other things that are
equally interested in,
you know,
because they alleviate some of the
pressure of what it is to be singularly
focused on one thing which we can get to
the point of madness in know unit does.
Yeah.
I got a drum kit I got really into
playing drums but six months ago just
to.
It's meditational man,
you have to relax to do it well and
you're not thinking about anything else.
And once I realized that,
I was like,
oh,
this is really good for me.
And uh,
but yeah,
that's my thing.
I'm.
So this music thing,
once it becomes a career,
you have to be singularly focused.
Especially when thinking about a record
man,
my wife,
she just kind of leaves me alone
while she sees me go to that weird
platelet processing place.
You know what I mean?
Because it's like she,
you know,
it's like nothing else is in the room
anyway for awhile and then I'm done and
you just feel like,
okay,
and then you don't write a song for a
year.
Well she seems very smart and support.
She could recognize that that's,
that's so important.
I have friends that are in relationships
where the wife is not very supportive
and it resists the creative process and
it gives them,
it doesn't understand it or
cheers was very creative too.
So she understands very independent.
So it's been an only child,
you know,
I,
she knows like there's just some times
where I have to go and be a mom.
Yeah,
space.
I just don't think you get to work
you're doing right now.
I don't think you get to that state
unless you're a little crazy.
You have to be.
You got to be locked into it,
man.
You know,
like by the way,
I'm so sorry I leaked the name of your
album out it.
I love it.
I really did on Instagram,
but it was fucking good man.
I was in the gym and uh,
and I said,
God damn,
people got to hear about this.
I was so high.
I was in Colorado and when you get high
in Colorado,
when you're at 8,000 feet or Utah,
actually 8,000 feet,
it just hits you in some crazy,
uh,
you feel like you're on a spaceship,
like on top of the world,
like your,
you're like,
I was feeling like I was connected to
the world and some really weird way and
it was at the gym just barbecued and
that,
that album was so.
It was so good,
especially in that moment at the gym.
Endorphins flowing.
And then he sent me a text,
hey man,
I think he leaked the name of the album.
I went,
oh no,
I didn't even think of that
man feel.
Honestly at this point it's uh,
this is definitely a record that
anybody that knows about me,
I would like them to hear as a record
because that's how I wrote,
recorded it to be heard.
Well,
that's one of the interesting aspects of
it.
Yeah.
It's obviously I'm one piece.
Well,
you um,
you sent me two versions of it,
it was kind of cool to,
or the people did,
they sent me one version which is just
one recording and then the other one is
side two and then another one where all
the songs were broken down individually
song.
But it almost feels like I shouldn't be
looking at that,
you know?
I mean ideally I would,
that's not how I wasn't designed to be
heard,
broken apart I guess.
But people like to hear like one song,
if they're in the car for 10 minutes on
the way home to like to hear one song,
it's not a bad thing.
Know all of my favorite records,
like have my top four or five records
are all concept records and most of them
are in song cycle,
which is
what they call it.
Like you know,
like dark side of the moon where it's
just one continuous wall,
the wall or the wall or what's going on.
But Marvin Gaye,
what's going on was one console and song
cycle that was written from the
narrative of a Vietnam vet returning
home to like an inner city home.
And trying to adapt to society.
Again,
it's a heavy album man.
And then astral weeks by Van Morrison,
if you've ever heard that record,
that's some powerful dope.
No,
I haven't.
Um,
it's all about the journey of your soul.
The soul's life.
Whoa.
I never got into van Morrison other than
she's one of my favorite songs ever.
I always wonder what that was.
That's what he called his commercial
album because astral weeks,
although it's now considered probably
one of the greatest records ever
recorded in silvery will because it was
two RC for a lot of people.
So then he turned around and
intentionally made a more commercially
accessible album.
She was moondance and course sold a
gazillion copies.
Whenever I think about Marvin Gaye,
I think about this check that date
because when Marvin Gaye got shot and
killed by his dad here in La,
right?
I don't know where he was in Los Angeles
by a tragic story.
He got shot and killed by his own
father.
The girl I was dating goes,
what kind of a horrible person must have
been that his dad shot him.
I went,
what
worked?
But that was how she viewed the world.
Like your father shot you.
You must have been a horrible person.
So fuck,
fuck him.
He's probably my favorite musician.
Veltassa.
I'll know more about Marvin Gaye then we
want to go into really as a really dark
story.
Yeah.
The council,
he's a,
there was a lot of that.
Him and his dad had things that stemmed
from childhood things.
Dad was a preacher one but also a cross
dresser.
And so Marvin I think was ridiculed a
lot and Carlotta shamed for that and his
dad was very strict,
really tyrannical
rule in the house and beat his mom a
lot.
So a lot of Marvin sexual deviancy later
on and they think probably stemmed from,
from some of that.
But I mean it was just a really highly
sensitive guy and in a genius at that,
uh,
don't know what kind of sexual deviancy
was he involved in war?
You never heard that.
I'm like,
err the gas dirty laundry.
But if there's books about it he's
doing,
he's like s and m bondage.
I think he had a free,
pretty substantial porn collection.
Oh,
okay.
Like the talk has a 17 year old
girlfriends and the [inaudible] and
threesomes and that kind of thing.
That was illegal back then.
He was just living,
Bro,
got on the radio and it went from there.
But I think after the height of his fame
and he was best selling record,
he was married to the daughter of the
president of motown or sister or one of
the other and she divorced him basically
and took everything like the whole
fortune and to smoking crack in a bread
truck and Hawaii and him.
This is after he's Marvin fucking gay.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
just went down hill from there.
Nobody could get to him or help him out.
So we had to move back in with his
parents as a grown ass man and while
he's Marvin fucking gay.
And then they think a lot of people say
that's where the source of all the
trauma and pain him going back to that,
at that stage in his life was the worst
thing that could have happened.
Being around his dad,
his dad apparently had an argument and
he,
uh,
told his dad like if he ever touched his
mom again,
he killed him and his dad said,
well,
if you ever lay a hand on me,
I'll kill you.
And I think on some people speculate
that Marvin was just so done with all of
it.
The fame and everything that he knew by
punching his father,
it would get him out of it was dad shot
him twice upstairs in the bedroom.
Oh my God.
And then the,
I think he laid there for about 20
minutes bleeding in the that the
ambulance showed up.
The paramedics couldn't come into the
House as long as the dad was still in
there with the gun.
So I think his sister in law brother
somebody to come in and like find the
gun that his father had hidden.
Who's?
He wasn't talking.
Oh Man.
It took.
So by the time they got him out of the
house,
Marvin died in the ambulance to the
hospital.
Woo.
That's heavy man.
Fuck
what a crazy story really said.
It is a terrible story.
It's you always.
When you,
when you hear about a guy that has this,
it's almost like overwhelming desire to
express himself,
you know,
like when you have a song like what's
going on or if you have a song like a
let's get it on,
you know,
devastating.
Come on.
I mean there's some intense memory
because emotional connection to what
he's doing is just so off the charts and
a lot of times that's almost like
energized by dark moments in your life.
Oh yeah.
Dark memories could,
it overwhelms those,
those pot.
Even the positive things.
You showed me a happy well adjusted
artists and I'll show you some boring
fucking art road.
Yeah,
let's get it on.
Shit that you got a girl that likes to
get.
Let's get it on.
You got a good one.
He,
I think she was 17 when he wrote that
album for really a little young
mistress.
Jesus,
that's dark.
Telling her how much he wanted to do the
deed for record 17.
So there's a song called really love to
ball
landed that album.
Really?
Yeah.
And it's just like women moaning and
orgasm and really goes was fearless man.
Shit.
Just get away with it too.
At that time it was probably sold so
many records,
so I
didn't tour.
He never toured.
Really?
Hardly ever really.
Couldn't drag him out on stage.
No.
Shit really.
I think when,
when let's get it on,
was blowing up.
He was living in a cabin up in top of
Topanga Canyon with his girlfriend and
just hiding from the world doing blow.
Literally.
He played one concert that entire record
cycle.
That's where everybody lived back then.
I saw Hendrix house was for sale a few
years back as a house at Hendricks
bought.
They never moved into.
He bought it right before he died.
I'll take it.
Even if even if he did live there,
I'm like,
I'll still buy it.
I need to know if he.
If he.
Did he write something anywhere?
It was it in paper that he walk in and
he was there.
He probably,
he must have bought it so he had to look
at it.
So if you looked at it,
he was in there.
So he walked around.
I take it.
He probably bone the realtor.
Fucking take it.
Well,
there was a house that was for sale that
was wilt Chamberlain's house that had
the whole deal.
It had a circular bed that spun around.
It was like the ultimate fuck castle and
you know,
will chamberlain on his way to Bang in
10,000 different women allegedly
according to him,
you know,
and he had just this insane bachelor
pad.
That was just.
How did he get anything else?
Look at it.
That's this house.
Look at that bad.
That's the way it looks like the enter
the Dragon.
Mr Han's fucking palace or something
is going on there,
bro.
Fuck yeah.
I'd be walking around and they're like
trying to find myself in the mirror.
Oh look at that shit a few years back.
That house is that the outside of it.
A few years back the house was for sale.
It's an epic epic house.
Like I'll fuck my dog too.
I'm not afraid.
But they had a really hard time selling
it because it was worth a lot of money.
That place,
man,
it was worth a lot of money and it
wasn't the kind of house that a normal
person could live in one bedroom
chamberlain's bungalow.
Would you see that now?
Look at the pool tables like whereas
knees are.
It's hilarious.
I wonder if that house ever sold.
It might be one of those things that you
just keep selling them buying,
but it's really funky.
Like modern for the 19 eighties.
Look in the crew man.
Oh yeah man,
look at that place.
It's all angular and shit.
Like a transformer to two and a half
acres.
Like it's.
You're expected to go
something like that.
So for now here,
even if it wasn't wilt Chamberlain's
house,
what's something that's a $10,000,000,
$10,000,000 depending on where it is.
If that's in the Hollywood hills.
Yeah.
That fucking crazy palace with the wave
pool is like,
look at all the.
I mean that's a piece of art that's not
just a house.
You'd have to have the right buyer.
What am I real estate guy flipping
houses all of a sudden,
fuck.
Do I know?
I don't even know how much toothpaste
cost
telling you how much this house is.
I'd say 10 million now.
It's a good number.
I want to say it's dope house.
No less than 10 million.
Two thousand seven.
It was 10 point five.
Bitch.
What the fuck?
I'm talking about white man tend to.
The point five is the negotiating.
That's where.
That's the wiggle room from 11 point
five,
so it's sold for eight years ago.
That's how much it was for sale.
It was listed at 11 point five.
Oh,
it was down to 10 point five.
So it might still be available.
No,
I bet.
Well,
I bet a house like that.
People buy it and they go,
what the fuck are we doing here?
Let's make some money.
It's in Bel Air and then they sell that
thing.
Oh,
bill there.
Yeah.
That's an expensive neighborhood.
Dope views must be good to be wilt
chamberlain back with no Internet.
No twitter,
no facebook.
Just all dick.
Yeah.
Those guys really just mean free for
all.
Oh yeah,
come on man.
It's chaos.
The president,
President Kennedy was on a free for all.
I mean,
imagine that the president just call him
buck wild.
What's amazing is that everyone in the
news,
like all the reporters,
they all knew it.
Yeah,
they didn't.
They didn't talk about it.
It was me stories written about it.
Well,
I wonder what that shift was.
The shift was in America where they
decided that they were just going to
talk about everything.
Like what caused sold.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Right.
Once I figured out that's all people
want is gossip was like once there was
too many different distribution methods,
it seems like that's what it is.
Right?
Like if you only have like a couple of
different newspapers and a couple of
different television shows,
it can all be kind of controlled.
I monopolize go.
Yeah.
And you also put pressure on the
reporters probably did not reveal that
stuff and that.
And I'm,
it's,
you
know,
like something on the radio in the car
when I was coming here about,
there was a big data models today.
Yeah.
I haven't gotten into it hurt the cliff
notes,
but it sounds pretty heavy.
It's supposed to be the biggest leak of
documentary millions of pages or.
Yeah,
and apparently it just shows all this
crazy collusion between world leaders
and financial.
I used to obsess about that shit and I
wanted to know,
you know,
like man,
but now at this stage in my life,
I mean
I just go ahead and assume it's all
fucking crooked and so it is definitely
all crooked,
but you know what I think,
man,
I don't even think.
I mean,
I think everybody's got to pay attention
to it obviously.
I mean we're all paying attention to it,
but I don't think it's sustainable.
I don't think you could do it anymore.
I think these leaks are going to come
more and more frequently and they're
going to be more and more accessible and
more and more easy to get.
I just don't think you're gonna be able
to fuck people like that anymore.
I just don't think you could do it.
Even the government,
I don't think they could do it anymore.
I think what they're doing now,
even right now,
they're like Klingon,
just hanging onto this thing while it's
shaken.
Apart around them,
because the apple fiasco and supposed to
be in control of us,
man,
that's the bottom line.
You're not supposed to be in control of
Jamie.
Jamie's not supposed to be in control of
me and the government's not supposed to
be in control.
You.
You're supposed to be some operating
principles that we all commune under and
our community should be established in a
way that benefits us.
Not the big banks,
not the politicians,
not fucking Hillary Clinton,
given $250,000 speaker speeches to a
bunch of Wall Street people.
That's all nonsense and that's some old
shit that we just assume we have to stay
with because it's been this way from the
jump.
It's been this way since we were kids.
While my parents grew up with it and
this is the system bullshit.
They're staying with this system.
Not because it's the best,
but because they figure the best way to
extract money from it.
You can't.
You're not gonna be able to do it.
It's not going to happen.
Once president trump gets in office,
everyone's going to realize what a
fucking God damn joke of a system we put
in place and there'll be some real talk
about having some kind of a radical
reform.
Like what if they could just fire
members of the Senate or the House
representatives or congress that you're
fired.
You can't just say,
we're not going to do our jobs.
Yeah.
Well,
dishes too many people that you don't
know that have any say whatsoever on how
you live your life,
like the idea that the Senate or that
Congress or that the Supreme Court and
these people could sit down and decide
like what you can can't do with your
body,
what substances you can or can't put
into them,
which shouldn't,
shouldn't be illegal like that.
You.
You shouldn't be able to decide that.
The Nixon thing the other day,
it was pretty interesting about where
they were just like,
yeah,
we should do anything.
We just,
you know.
Yeah.
We'll tell people what it was.
They.
There was a former aide,
I think.
Was that,
was that right?
Somebody in his.
Yeah.
Someone basically came out and said that
the war on drugs was propagated to
suppress minorities and a anti war
movement,
Antiwar Movement,
and they,
they knew that there was no threat there
and it wasn't doing anything harmful to
people and and basically they're on tape
talking about it and laughing.
Unbelievable.
Somebody on late night the other night
when it came out,
they said it perfectly like that.
Even from the grave.
That guy manages to cultivate more
fucking hatred.
It was so crazy.
Dude.
What?
Evil Bastard.
Yeah.
It was last week.
Quote from Richard Nixon's former chief
domestic advisor,
John Eric,
Eric,
Min e h r I c h Dot Heckman surfaced
confirming a disgusting truth that's
been very well known by black folks for
for several decades of war on drugs.
Had nothing to do with eradicating it
drug epidemic.
Instead,
it was a ploy to hide for the
intentional targeting and decimating of
the black community.
Well,
as well as the real thing.
This is Eric Men's words.
He said the Nixon campaign in 1968 in
the Nixon White House after that had two
enemies.
The antiwar left and black people.
You understand what I'm saying?
We knew that we couldn't make it illegal
to be either against the war or black,
but by getting the public to associate
the hippies with marijuana and the
blacks with heroin and then
criminalizing both heavily,
we could disrupt those communities.
Wow.
We could arrest their leaders,
raid their homes,
break up their meetings,
and vilify them night after night on the
evening news.
Holy fucking shit.
Did we know we were lying about drugs?
Of course we did.
Whoa.
Damn.
That's dark.
That guy's only concentrating on black
people though.
Do you go to an all black site that guys
just wants to talk about?
The black part is you got a big smiling
black phase.
The whole thing is disgusting.
It's disgusting that we live under the
echoes of all these morons that were
running the country back then.
All these creeps that could get away
with shit just like wilt chamberlains up
there banging up a storm and Marvin
Gaye's cooked up into pain canyon with a
17 year old.
You can get away with anything back
then.
Apparently.
You still can't.
R Kelly.
Paula r Kelly allegedly,
but that's,
you know,
Dick Cheney,
you could just shoot people the fucking
face.
Literally.
Yeah.
Well those.
Do you know what he was doing?
It's a canned hunt.
So those are weird man.
Do you know what that is?
That's really go out and you're
basically guaranteed a trophy.
No bird hunting.
So what happens is they go out and they
um,
they open up these fucking boxes of
birds and the birds fly out and they
shoot them and he's still shot somebody
in the face to face and he didn't talk
about.
He wouldn't talk to anybody for like 16
hours afterwards was probably hammered.
He was hammered,
man.
Most likely he was hammered.
Allegedly.
Can you still sue?
Even though it doesn't have a heart,
it was like an artificial heart.
She's still out of Su,
but he shot his friend in his face and
his friend apologized.
That's how fucking gangster Dick Cheney
is.
While his friend was like 60 walked it
off when she walked in front of your
bullets,
Bro,
they would probably live out of their
fucking mind.
Just that you want to talk about ptsd.
Do you imagine the demons inside the
brain of Dick Cheney,
the,
just knowing what he knows,
could you imagine?
I mean,
if that guy has an ounce of self
realization,
an ounce of,
of objectivity,
of introspective thought,
whereas really thinks about it than I do
the right thing was I do think.
Do you think,
um,
that um,
weapons of mass destruction,
you think that was cool?
Was that okay?
There's only a few hundred thousand
dollars a million people died,
but that it was probably for the best
historically.
I mean,
they were going to die anyway.
It's not like there are a million of
mortals,
right?
I mean,
what you're asking about,
do I think he was president?
Dick Cheney seeks daily affirmation.
Well,
he's a biblical character in that right
after he had done all these things
right,
but he'd clearly pulled the strings to
get us into Iraq.
And there's clearly financial motives.
I mean,
he was the god Damn Ceo of the company
that got into no bid,
billion dollar contract.
Palpatine man,
he's a damn sith Lord.
Like Bush,
like him or hate him.
He thought he was doing the right thing.
You know the guy believed,
but this is the thing to undeniable
biblical thing about him.
So the guy has a ton of heart attacks,
right?
Yeah.
They replaced his fucking heart.
They replaced his valves with some
machine and this machine constantly pump
blood to the point where he didn't have
a pulse.
It was a constant flow.
So if you put your finger on Dick Cheney
while he had this artificial heart in
place,
he wouldn't have a pulse.
Started vader.
He's dark vader.
He's fucking darth vader.
Like the old man at the era,
the promethium that was pretending to be
dead and shit.
You pull.
Make sure that's true.
I'm pretty sure I'm correct about that.
Jamie.
Pull that up about about Dick Cheney's
heart being artificial and not having a
pulse.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was just reading about the actual
event and how it happened and he shot
him in the face and they blamed the guy
waiting this name for walking in front
of them.
Had a fucking idiot.
Listen,
man,
you don't point your gun where people
are.
The guy didn't walk in front of you.
That's crazy.
As a person who fires guns,
you don't ever point your gun anywhere
near a person.
If a person walks in front and you pull
your gun away from where that person is,
if you have to be aware of your left and
your right at all times,
you don't stand in front of somebody.
The guy didn't just.
It's not that guys fault bionic.
Dick Cheney technically has no pulse
here.
It goes during recent heart surgery at
doctors and planted a ventricular assist
device to augment Cheney's failing
ticker,
but it also gives us critics and other
punch line to work with because the
device moves blood continuously.
It doesn't mimic the pulsating rhythm of
the heartbeat.
Tactically speaking,
Dick Cheney no longer has a pulse in
insert darth vader comparisons here.
This is a 2010 and that's still kicking.
That's amazing,
man.
I used to do this bit about Dick Cheney
where you had one extra secret service
agent,
like every other guy had five,
but he had six and this one,
they put them on like this all
vegetarian diet and they had to do
jogging every day.
He's like,
why the fuck do I have to jog?
And there was always a guy behind them
with a a giant cooler filled with ice.
And the moment Dick Cheney has a heart
attack,
they were going to take that dude out,
cut his chest open,
shove his heart inside a Dick Cheney and
Save Dick Cheney was one extra secret
service agent that was a sacrifice.
He's a dark guy,
man.
He,
he was the CEO of the company that
profited the most from them blowing shit
up in Iraq
rope
around the time that I was in the navy,
the uh,
they had this reimplemented,
this anthrax vaccination policy and it's
a,
I think they've done it in the first
Gulf War Two and a lot of people think
is directly responsible for the Gulf War
syndrome and all those guys like dealing
with chronic muscle spasms and fatigue.
And really,
um,
so yeah,
but like they,
they came down the pipeline again.
They're gonna,
they're gonna make it a mandatory thing
for everybody.
And then I think in [inaudible] 98,
they recalled it,
I can't remember.
[inaudible] 98 or 99 with the times and
all these people had already kind of dug
in and figured out that there was only
one lab in the entire world authorized
and regulated to manufacture the vaccine
call.
I think their lab was bioport up in
Michigan and one of the owners of the
lab was a former admiral of the navy and
also in the joint chiefs of staff
things.
Last thing was crow and this guy.
So you're telling me that dude didn't
know that this contract is major bit
multibillion dollar defense contract
coming down the pipeline and then jumps
in and buys this company,
you know,
to start pumping people with shit that
they have no idea.
And they actually got the lab got shut
down while they're manufacturing all
this stuff.
Who knows how many hundreds of thousands
of people had to put that shit in there
and they will fucking experiment on
soldiers.
They have done it in the past is the
precedent has been set a long time go.
Oh yeah.
I remember bootcamp.
You go down those cattle catalog and
there's like six people and you just
keep going through and you go through
with all of these shots,
guns that just.
I have no idea to this day where a lot
of it even was.
Man,
I got stationed overseas so we had to
take a bunch of typhoid and there's a
whole lot of shit on.
They don't even tell you what they're
putting in you,
you know,
for a week.
You can't lift your arms up.
Like
how fucked is that?
They don't have.
They don't have to tell you.
No.
That's crazy that they can just shoot
vaccinations in you and they don't have
to tell you what they're doing.
I refused to take them.
They put you in prison really?
Or the brick,
you know,
like a lot of guys.
How long they put you in for until you
get in new guys.
I think it was like 90 days restricts
it.
Yeah.
And then they don't know.
I'll have to shoot you when he get out.
No,
no,
no.
It's not like that.
It's just a,
it's one of those.
But I mean it was obviously about making
money.
Fuck or no,
because I'm an anthro sale.
Okay.
So you get hit with weaponized anthrax
or you've even if you've been
vaccinated,
it's a spore.
It's a virus.
It's going to mutate as soon as it hits
the air.
So,
you know,
I guess the argument of the reasoning
was that it might make you live 30 or 40
extra seconds longer so you can hit the
button to launch some more missiles at
them.
I don't know what the reasoning behind
it was,
but uh,
yeah,
a lot of it was a big deal.
I remember when that story came out,
they found out that the admiral owned
the company was like,
wait a what?
So crazy.
This is illegal.
It's so crazy.
I wonder if he took the shot,
I doubt it.
Wide
Gulf War Syndrome was uh,
connected to depleted uranium.
Maybe it was a several,
several different factors,
so
many different factors because they know
that they definitely used depleted
uranium shells as anti tank weapons
that's been proven and that was
something that they were never supposed
to use.
And the half life on that shit is
something like 100,000 years or
something nutty.
So there's these places in Iraq to this
day that are just Foxville from these,
these depleted uranium shells slamming
into tanks and soldiers would take
pieces from those tanks as memories,
you know,
they take them home as souvenirs and so
you're carrying something that's highly
radioactive,
like those depleted uranium shells.
It's laid literally nuclear waste and
they use that as a shell and it just
goes through everything.
I mean,
you're harnessing the power of the sun,
the blow a hole through a jeep.
And then these poor fuckers,
you know,
they,
they stumble upon this jeep and nobody
had told them shit and they're like,
hey man,
I take this license plate home.
You shouldn't even be anywhere near
that.
You shouldn't even be a mile away from
that fucking jeep.
Meanwhile,
they're hanging around that God damn
thing.
Who knows,
man,
my grandfather was in the South Pacific
during World War Two and even as an
older man,
he must have gotten something in his
blood over there because it'd be like
middle of July and he'd be sitting in
the house with like long johns and
corduroy pants and a flannel shirt on
and talk about I'm cold,
you know,
she's just like.
So I mean,
there must have been cemented as nerve
gas
or.
Well,
maybe even just tropical diseases.
I talked to this,
this um,
guy.
He's a,
um,
uh,
an expert infectious diseases.
His name is Peter Hotez.
He's a,
um,
professor I think at the University of
Houston.
Um,
but he's a specializes in diseases that
people get in tropical climates.
And he told me that when you look at a
tropical environment,
100 percent of those people are infected
with some sort of parasite,
$100 silver built a resistance to it.
Well,
they just,
they or not,
or they're affected by it.
Like we were talking about all sorts of
different moisture born bacterial
diseases that people get from dirty
water and stuff that you just get from
bugs and you get from the air and
jungleman.
You're basically living in a petri dish.
Yup.
You live in a nice shit's coming to life
every day.
I mean,
if you think about the jungle,
right?
If you go there and you see all that
vegetation ever around you,
it's just a life and crickets and bugs
and snakes and spiders and cats at
fucking sloths and eagles and real
monkeys and shed.
Whoa.
Like there's so much life there that
it's at a macro level too.
It's at a micro level,
like there's life that you're not going
to see.
It's going to get into your body,
crawling up your asshole right now while
you're swimming or you know,
eat becomes a part of you.
Like they,
they have these parasites that become a
part of you.
A buddy of mine got tricky gnosis foul
dude.
Jesus.
He got tricky gnosis from eating a bear
meat that wasn't cooked that well.
Actually it was on the show.
His name is Steven.
Ellie's a hosted the show called
mediator and he was on the show with a
bunch of other crew members.
They all eat this bear and they all
didn't cook it.
Well,
they didn't cook it well enough and they
were joking about getting trick and
hostess at the time.
So they all got trick analysis so they
have these little tiny worms,
these larva that are in their body
forever growing.
Well,
they don't grow.
They just stayed dormant in your body
until someone comes along and say if you
ate Steven Rinella and you didn't cook
them to 160 degrees,
you would get tricky gnosis from them.
Like it's in him for just.
Yeah,
just part of the deal.
And he said he was like really deathly
sick for like seven days.
Felt like shit.
Like you had the flu in pain all the
time is aching and pain and then it went
away and then it just.
You just deal with the fact that now you
have a trick analysis.
But like in these tropical environments,
there's tons of people that have all
sorts of crazy parasites in their body,
dysentery or malaria or any damn yeah.
And in some parasites,
they're just starting to now understand
this parasites that affect behavior.
Like there's some shit called
toxoplasmosis.
You heard of that one.
The cat parents plasmosis get you
fucking die from smelling bird shit,
dude.
One of the creepiest stories I've ever
heard was guys in Africa,
they were standing in front of a cave
thing was Africa and they were standing
in front of a cave and there were
scientists and they wanted to photograph
these birds fly.
Are these bats rather flying out of the
cave when they would go out at night
because you know the bats leave caves
and mass and there was millions of bats,
literally millions of bats in this cave.
And so they parked out in front of this
cave,
set up the calls and shit to shit on.
That's what they didn't anticipate.
All the flying out of the shit on.
And they got deathly ill and they were
dead within weeks.
Both guys died.
They died.
This whole thing on tv about the dive
viruses,
which means they start bleeding on their
fucking eyeballs.
That's what you get for going and
looking at in bat caves,
man.
Well,
bring raincoats on some goggles.
Yeah,
man.
You gotta don't eat it.
Definitely don't eat it,
but it gets in your skin like you can't
have that shit on your skin.
You can get sick just from it contacting
your face a bat dirty bat shit.
Shit's on your face.
You could probably die.
I'd want to.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
There's so many parts of the world where
there's so much life and that life is so
much more dangerous.
We're just so used to life being like,
oh look at the squirrel.
I love wildlife.
Look at that bird.
So cute.
But you always hear about these people
like talking about going down to Ecuador
and Peru to do.
I asked him like,
fuck that.
I don't want to go through that damn
jungle with those bugs and caterpillars
and shit.
Snakes crawling up my leg.
They say that's part of the experience
is going to the jungle,
but yeah,
you could do that in Malibu.
You can do it in Malburg,
man.
You can just sit down in the house.
I'll do the cliff notes.
The cliff notes is DMT,
man.
I think going to the jungle probably be
pretty bad ass.
But you have running around.
Yeah.
You have to have people that are awake
with spotlights and guns.
Yeah.
You don't want to be that one dude that
goes to South American.
It's jacked by a leopard will just sleep
in this tree.
Jaguar.
But Jaguar,
Jaguar,
South America,
right.
Leopards.
Uh,
Africa,
Asia.
That sounds right.
So yeah,
man,
this has been a national geographic
podcasts.
They oftentimes are.
You knew a guy named Steve Mirrors.
Mirrors Huy spelled last name.
He's a British guy.
He's like a naturalist in those.
He's like A.
Probably a master survival is put a,
I think it's Mirror Steve.
Look it up,
Steven Mirrors,
man.
You should try to get him on the show
sometimes.
I used to,
I used to sit and just watch hours of
youtube videos.
He's like one of these.
You just tell her just like a beautiful
human being,
but he knows all about,
um,
it's like bear grylls and Mr Rogers,
you know what I mean?
But bind together,
but a little more legit.
Real bear grylls.
Yeah.
Bear grylls.
Legit.
Oh,
girls got compromised by Hollywood.
Hollywood.
Do you know why bear grylls got that
show?
I have no idea.
Some inflammation drinking is piss.
Nope.
Les Stroud,
survivor man did not want to fake
anything.
Less.
Drought did all his own shit.
He went by himself.
He put himself in dangerous situations.
He lost tons of weight on camera,
whereas literally starving to death,
he documented the entire thing in 100
percent by himself.
Encounters with wild animals,
like really dangerous situations.
Almost starving to death,
almost freezing to death,
having to make fire on your own and
going there with a very limited amount
of things to keep.
Like you would go there with like a
pocket knife.
You'll allow themselves some string that
he could go fishing with go and he would
stay for seven days and have a dropoff
point where they would drop them off and
then it pick up point and if he didn't
go to the pickup point and they didn't
have to go looking for them,
but they wanted to fake stuff and bear
bear grylls filled that gap because les
whitten fake anything.
It's like,
no,
we not bringing a camera crew because
then it's not me by myself that you lose
all of what makes the show special.
So what he did is just a bunch of things
that they set up.
Like if I found these sheep,
I could take it and make a coat.
You know,
like the shit they put the sheep there,
they killed the sheep,
they did it for them.
I keep doing all these stunts,
like jumping from tree to tree and
unnecessarily hanging out with hippo is
this guy.
No Steve Black Shawl.
I can't find a Steve Bowles's last name.
Ray mears premier's just guys hanging
out with hippos because that guy's
saying ray mears,
gangs for.
There's a show called Carter's war and
it's this show about this guy who is an
anti anti poaching official in Africa
and he tries to prevent them from
poaching all these animals.
A lot of it is for the Asian market,
for Rhino Horn and a bunch of these
different animals that they want like
ivory and Rhino Horn is a big one
though.
They keep finding these rhinos murdered
with their horns,
hacked off.
It's a fucking sobering show,
man,
for two reasons.
One,
because you see what people are willing
to do.
These animals just shoot them in the
head and cut their horns off and cut
half their face off like a chainsaw and
shit.
It's crazy.
And then also you see how fucking poor
these people are and then you realize
like they of course they're going to do
that.
Like if they can shoot that rhino and
make $50,000 from its magic corn or
whatever the fuck they make,
they probably make 50 bucks,
you know?
But if they can make that,
it's between them starving and not
starving.
Like that's literally what you're
looking at.
Everything subjective.
Just the gentlemen that's him shows
called Bushcraft,
those crafts hanging out with a wolf.
Look at this motherfucker.
He knows the wolves.
He's like,
he's like the most unassuming guy,
but he's so bad ass dude.
It's called bushcraft.
Bushcraft.
Is it an English show or an
Australia on the BBC I believe.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Doodle.
Just walk out in the woods with nothing
but a damn or there.
Is there a fish
with like some piece of meat or
something they got.
Yeah.
These guys that are into like surviving
on their own like that.
They take great pleasure with that.
They're always fascinating.
I guess he's really naturalist to like
Fanta and natural vegetation and finding
forging food on your own that contains a
lot more useful information than just,
okay,
you got three days,
drink your pis and don't get eaten by
the alligator.
Like no man will.
Survivor man came up,
came up with all that on his own.
His concept,
because he was actually living in the
forest with his pregnant wife.
The two of them,
they are by themselves.
When he was a younger man,
like he did this on his own before,
you know,
before he was famous,
like he's been doing this forever.
What's his background?
Where do you learn it all?
He just,
I don't know,
man.
That's a good question.
He told me I forgot.
I think he just learned to read a lot of
suffering for those 30 minutes of
viewing entertainment.
He's got this wacky thing he's doing now
and always looking for bigfoot.
He's got a survivor man.
Big Foot is like the biggest thing since
sliced bread.
Leavenworth Washington.
That's where he is.
Do you see him?
Yeah,
so when we got a cup of coffee on the
road one day,
this lady had a whole photo album full
of pictures of bigfoot in her backyard.
It looked like some bullshit,
like our neighbor jacket off.
She's selling coffee though.
I talked to One lady when I was doing
this,
a Scifi show.
We did a whole episode on bigfoot one
lady that I really believe saw something
a really believe she did,
but what I think she probably saw was a
black bear because black players walk on
their hind legs.
Um,
there's video of black bears walk in
like 100 yards from her.
She was very earnest and what she was
talking about and was sensational in
any,
in any way at all.
What she was telling me,
it was pretty,
pretty straightforward.
And I also believe her because there's
black bears in that area.
It's incredibly densely wooded.
Like the area that she's talking about
was the Pacific northwest.
Oh yeah man.
I guess Mount Rainier,
Mt.
Rainier.
That's right outside of Washington,
right outside of Seattle.
It's gorgeous.
Big Harry fucked her is real.
That's the only place he could possibly
exist because you could absolutely
disappeared in that forest.
Yup.
That's some dense,
dense wilderness and filled with food
filled with food filled with wildly
known me saying,
I believe in bigfoot.
Yeah.
You're,
you're 100 percent correct though.
If there was an animal like that,
that would be the spot.
It also would be the spot because that's
the spot where it would make sense
geographically.
My feeling is what I believe.
I bet
it used to be real because at one point
in time there was a thing called
gigantic pithy kiss that lived in Asia.
It was as recently as 100,000 years ago,
which is not that long and that was when
the bering strait was connected,
so Asia and the United States,
you could actually walk from Asia to the
United States that the land mass was in
place and the ice age and was all frozen
over.
So during that time it would have been
entirely possible because so many native
American cultures have names for that
animal to have names for this.
Like man that lives in the forest is
how's the same legend on the other side
of the world about some crazy well,
and it was real.
Right?
And then also on top of that thing being
real.
They also know that there was those
little hobbit people in the island of
Flores and there's a theory about that
thing is that it's either the most
recent one.
They think that it might've been as
recently as 50,000 years ago,
but I think they thought it was like
14,000 years ago until recently.
Look at this.
That's a bear dude.
That is a bear.
Look at that.
That's a real legit black bear.
So imagine if you saw that for sure.
That's big fish.
So that last little.
See when bears hurt there Paul.
Like if they get bitten in there,
Paul and their pod gets infected.
They can walk on their back legs and
they can do it for hundreds of yards.
So I think she saw that just when you
thought they couldn't get any scarier.
There's a bunch of videos of bear's
doing that.
It's not just that one bear.
So there's a lot of evidence that bears
walk like that.
So this one lady that I talked to,
I bet she saw a black bear that was
walking on time.
Legs.
That's what.
I bet.
It only makes sense.
You can't see anything in there.
Anyway,
that's the thing about those woods.
You lived up there right in the car for
a minute.
Yeah.
You can't see shit in those woods.
No.
We used to go.
Just look a little weird Swiss mountain
ski town called Living Worth.
I don't know,
a buddy of mine.
We drove through on our way to Vancouver
to go party and there was another,
it was like farther east,
I think it was like,
you know,
in the middle of nothing man,
just trees.
You could,
you could just walk off into it and
disappear.
Well less.
When he was camping,
he was doing an episode of survivor and
it was up in Alaska and he says that he
heard some noise outside of his tent and
he barely moved.
Like he didn't,
he didn't want to move.
We wanted to see if he could get his
camera and uh,
try to record this and he heard
something that sounded like a primate,
something like
made like some primate type noise.
And then when he went to open up his
tent and look outside,
the thing took off,
took off running.
And he said it sounded like bipedal
footprints.
I go large,
heavy,
bipedal thing.
The problem is I've heard bears make
that kind of sound.
I've heard them personally,
seen them with my eyes fighting with
each other.
They they make like
a almost like a gorilla and they're
attacking each other and they were
making this crazy noise.
It was a mother trying to keep a male
bear away from her cubs.
And she was.
They fought.
They fought right in front of us,
like within a hundred yards.
I watched him duke it out,
UFC style Alberta.
I was watching it go down.
So I've heard bears make like a monkey
sound that makes much more practical
sense to me than a seven foot tall
chewbacca that no one's ever seemed to
be able to play.
Eyes are more hands on,
you know?
Well we got drones now,
man.
I wanted to believe so bad.
That's why the one thing I want to
believe in bigfoot almost as much as
aliens as Ufo reports,
aliens and Ufo is like the one that's
the one two punch for what you want to
believe in,
man.
Yeah.
Other than love.
Well that too.
I don't know.
We don't want to go down that rabbit
hole.
Yeah,
black holes and infinite multi versus.
Well,
I,
without a doubt,
you go to school out there that were
the.
Yeah.
I guess the question is why would they
fucking care?
Well,
or maybe they do.
I mean,
maybe this is pretty interesting.
I'd watch it for sure.
I mean,
come on,
man.
We studied turtles.
You know,
dudes traveled to the jungle to study of
fucking butterfly.
Some heavy stuff going on the back of a
turtle.
Joe Rogan.
That's true.
Not to demean turtles.
Look,
if turtles were on the moon,
oh my God,
we'd be flying jets to,
to visit the oldest known species on
earth day crocodiles.
Really?
Whoa.
Yeah.
Turtles been around longer than any
other living creature on the planet.
They're like,
um,
nail clippers.
They never had to make them any better.
That's perfect design.
Yeah.
Like when I was a kid,
nail clippers are exactly the same.
They haven't done anything.
I mean,
they made better can openers.
They've made a better tupperware.
They've improved almost every aspect.
I guess steak knives are pretty much the
same.
Even even the number of,
uh,
like the,
the,
the Shill,
you know,
the,
like the symmetrical patterns of the
shoulders.
13,
no matter how big are they are small.
So like all Indians believe that that
coincided with the 13 lunar cycles of
the moon.
Yeah.
I made a whole album cover all about
this shit.
I was just letting you know,
the guys like how weird can we get with
this thing?
Just make the tackiest record cover ever
day are a very fascinating creature.
I mean anytime you see patterns like
even like a Nautilus Shell,
see these patterns,
these repeating patterns that the
animals have.
Like,
you know,
okay,
well why is there as some sort of a
geometric pattern into this animal's
design?
You know,
almost fractal.
Really?
Oh,
it is.
It's.
Well,
it's a FIBONACCI
sequence.
The FIBONACCI sequence manifests itself
in like sunflowers.
Like they say,
like if you look at a pine cone on the
FIBONACCI sequences in a pine cone,
meaning that it's a sequence of numbers
like zero.
And then there's one and then there's.
And then there's two and one plus two.
There's three and three plus two is
five,
and the five plus three is eight and it
keeps going on and on and on,
and it's this exponential equation and
when you're adding all those things up,
that same sequence can be found in the
shape of people's faces and honeycombs
and a bunch of different designs like
pine cones.
There's very.
See Jamie's got some stuff.
They pull up a bit.
The FIBONACCI numbers in nature.
There's this crazy green fruit that's
always at my,
uh,
might be a vegetable.
That's it.
What is that fucking thing that fruit?
Broccoli?
What does it.
Romanesque Broccoli,
romanesque Broccoli.
It's like the DMT fruit,
like when you look at that,
like that is fractal geometry in fruit
form or in vegetable form or other
really weird.
But that's the FIBONACCI sequence.
Like if you go to the very top and you
see how small it is and then it as it
tapers down,
it gets larger and the numbers all
exponentially increased.
It's just so fascinating.
Tool.
Yeah.
Was of a music.
The band when I was younger,
do you know that?
Uh,
maynard key is going to fight Ronda
Rousey and an MMA match.
Did Not know that.
Knew He.
When he loses,
he's getting an exchange.
You're bullshitting me.
Of course.
I am trying to help spread a rumor.
Awesome.
I'll show you some pictures afterwards.
He does.
Is he like a Jujitsu Guy?
I believe he's got his purple belt.
I'm pretty sure he goes about,
but he's very dedicated.
He's so dedicated.
You got a hip replacement and went back
to training.
But here it goes.
Five Rhonda Rogers Kit that look at it.
Awesome.
He's a fucking
character.
I love that dude.
Ever him?
Oh yeah.
Hung out with them.
Really cool.
He's been on the show a couple times.
He's a good dude.
Was one of my lyricist,
man.
Yeah,
a really.
When I lived out there and he was a
little kinds of music I just discovered
that I probably never would have gotten
into otherwise.
And that band I really like had a little
phase lyrically speaking.
I thought it was some of the more
Cathartic and kind of start donek stuff
I've ever heard.
Really intelligent way of saying things.
I just never metal guy,
he's almost too smart for his own good.
He's one of those guys when he talked to
me like this,
you,
you might be just in your own way all
the time.
So it's one of the reasons why thank.
He decided to start a wine business out
of in the middle of nowhere just.
And his wine is fucking excellent.
I don't know if you're a wine person if
you like wine,
but caduceus wine.
I just know what I like and I love it.
It's great.
He has a bunch of different kinds of
ones,
but uh,
he's,
he's a legit wizard when it comes to
winemaking.
He really knows his shit inside and out.
It's not like some sort of a thing that
he leaned,
lends his name to,
you know,
like fucking orson wells.
We will sell no wine before it's time.
No,
he,
this is his wine company,
like he has created it and he's also
like figured out a way to cultivate
grapes and it's very weird spot in
Arizona.
Well,
I don't think anybody was doing it
before him,
so he had to start the thing from
scratch.
He did the whole thing for years.
Doing it for years.
He's nuts,
man.
We've had some long ass conversations
about it.
Yeah,
he's one of the coolest people that I
talked to at the time.
That's Ballsy,
man,
because you don't.
I might be wrong,
but I think you have to bring in a
couple harvest and then you won't even
know if the grapes are going to be any
good.
That's a good spot for it.
So you're putting all this money up.
Well,
you have to analyze the soil and you
have to know what you're doing as far as
fertilizing it and all those all.
There's so many factors involved and how
to.
I mean it's an art.
It's a crazy art that you'd wind up
eating.
You wind up drinking at the very end of
it,
but creating the taste.
It's like the expression of the art
instead of an audible thing,
like a song.
It becomes a palette thing,
but it's a very much like the way he
creates music.
He creates this wine and it's a form of
art.
It's like a mass produce,
not mass produced,
you know,
like Coca Cola,
but it's making more than one bottle.
He's got several acres and he creates
this art and you experienced that art
instead of listening to a CD.
Experiencing that art when you drink is
one very fascinating guy,
man.
They just played in Nashville not long
ago.
It was on tour or I probably would have
gone,
but yeah,
I'd say top five shows of all time.
Wildlife tools.
Probably at least two of those spots.
Really?
Yeah,
Dude.
Wow.
Yeah,
a lot.
I mean it's just,
they're so incredibly tight glove just
aesthetically in the presentation and
it's sent,
you know,
most like big,
loud metal shows.
It's just as well.
Right,
right.
It was,
it was pristine,
like sound wise and the drummers of
machine.
Yeah.
Dana Carey.
I wouldn't put them in a metal category.
Maybe I'd be,
I don't know
what you'd call it.
It's,
it was so unique.
I don't remember hearing it even.
I'm thinking that's very,
uh,
some complex shit going on,
man.
Yeah.
We're talking about like motivating
songs that,
that riff in that song.
Prison sex.
No,
the beginning down,
down,
down.
When you're lifting weights and that
comes on,
you can lift more weights,
man.
You can lift more weights.
You feel stronger.
You like if you're tired,
you don't on the elliptical machine that
comes on you like you could fucking push
through.
I mean it does something to your body.
It energizes you.
Like that's a real feeling that you get.
We don't think of it as a real feeling
because he can't put it on a scale for
visceral music.
Something's happening to you when you
listened to a jam.
That's
correct.
Oh,
I mean,
I,
you know,
you hate to think about though,
and those guys actually experimented
with frequencies and a lot of those deep
down pitch tunings and time signatures
are varies.
Very,
very,
very eastern melodion time signatures
that they're alternating in the,
off down.
It's,
it's heavy shit,
heavy,
like they put thought into that music.
Well,
the one song that they orchestrated to
that,
you can totally manipulate human
emotions with tones and keys and
vibration as well.
Have you ever fucked around with
binaural beats?
I mean,
not for fun or like on record either for
fun.
I haven't done it either way,
but I know that it's real.
I mean I know that people swear by it.
It affects your brainwaves.
There's a reason all these trials
throughout history,
out in the middle of nowhere or banging
on drums will know when they're doing
their thing.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
There's a ICAROS.
You've got all those.
I don't know how they say that.
You play when you do dmt and the DMT
entities danced to the ICO.
Rose.
I mean like it's a part of the thing,
like when you do them together then you
understand.
If you listen to the music
independently,
like fucking weird music.
It's kind of trippy,
but it's weird.
I think this is meant for people.
That hundred percent.
Yeah.
Well this is created by a shaman.
This,
this the one that I have on my phone
that I play is created by a shaman.
It's by this guy.
Let me see if I was homeboy's name here.
I think his name is actually on the um,
on the recording itself.
God Damn it.
I don't have it on this.
I was going to say that you think it's
meant.
I mean other than the people who are
naturally from those areas where these
things grow out of the ground and occur
and they use them to connect with on a
religious level,
their spirit animals and things they
believe in,
but you like the tourists going down
there and drinking that shit.
Uh,
how do you feel about that?
Well,
it's like everything else.
You're going to get legit ones and then
you're going to get people that realize
there's a lot of money in tourists
coming out here and taking this wacky
shared.
And so they figured out how to make it.
So you're going to get people that are
taking advantage of people.
You got to get people that are doing all
sorts of negative shit and then you're
going to get legit Shaman people that
are legitimately involved in the
spiritual quest of attaining
enlightenment and reaching a neighboring
dimension,
like they really believe that they're
reaching a neighboring dimension that
they're tapping into something that's
around us all the time,
but then we don't have access to in a
normal state of consciousness.
And it's a well of souls who tapping
into.
It's something.
I mean,
it's real easy to dismiss,
especially for someone never experienced
it.
It's
really easy to dismiss and say it's all
in your imagination,
but for someone who has experienced it,
it's very difficult to accept.
And it's very difficult for you to say
that you know,
for sure that it's all your imagination
if you haven't experienced it.
I see.
It's a very,
I appreciate from a,
from a,
um,
uh,
an intelligence standpoint,
someone's perspective on it that hasn't
experienced it.
But the reality is,
until you know what you're talking,
until you've actually gone into that
thing and know how titanic,
the alien it is,
you really just saying things,
you're just making noises with your
mouth and you know what?
There's no way you could know.
It's not like it's,
well,
I had a dream once and it was kind of
saying,
no,
it's.
You're not there anymore.
You go to a different place.
You experience a different reality.
More real than what we normally
interpret it as reality.
That's the most fucked up part about it
is it's so much crisper and more vibrant
and brighter,
and then reality itself seems muted in
some odd way.
It's almost like we're,
we're,
we're like having sex with a condom on,
you know,
and a big thick fucking trash bag,
condom.
And when you pass through to whatever
the fuck this other dimension is that
filter the,
the,
the frosted window is removed and you
could see it all the fog is gone,
the clouds are gone and you just boom,
gets shot through a cannon to the middle
of reality.
And that middle of reality of some
strange geometric living environment
where there's no,
um,
there's no three dimensional objects in
it that aren't touching each other.
Everything is connected to everything
else.
Like there's a bunch of different
things.
They're constantly alternating all the
time,
but there's no space between anything.
There's no space between you and me.
Not In that world.
It doesn't exist.
There's no space.
Everything is.
Everything is all together.
It's all together.
And you feel altogether like for the
first time ever,
you don't feel like you're sitting in
Canoga Park in a chair with a roof over
your head and above that roof of the sky
and above the skies the moon.
You don't feel that when you're in this,
you feel like you feel down infinite.
You feel to the left and to the right,
infinite.
You feel above.
But you also feel like you're in a room
and it feels fractal and it's,
oh,
it's fucking crazy.
So,
I mean,
it might all be in your imagination,
but my take on it has always been,
even if it is,
even if you're not going to a well of
souls and experiencing God and
experiencing purity and wisdom,
it's the same exact experience as if you
were so.
Even if it is in your imagination,
your imagination has pretty cool.
Fucking amazing.
I mean it might,
it might be.
That's what you're experiencing it.
It very well might be.
It's you don't know,
and there's no way to tell.
It's easy to be cynical.
It's easy to be dismissive.
It's easy to say,
oh,
come on,
he's fucking hippies.
They think they're experiencing God
through some powder that they smoke in a
way to go meet head.
Yeah.
You really are.
It's a really.
I mean,
it's cute.
It's fun to do.
It's easy to dismiss it,
but once you do it,
there's no dismissing it.
When you're there,
There's no easy explanation.
There's no easy anything.
Once you're there,
once you're in there,
you better let go.
Bitch.
You better go.
You better not try to fucking wrap your
head around this,
just breathe and try not to freak out.
And with that note,
ladies and gentlemen,
what are you doing in town?
Man?
I got to do A.
I gotta.
I gotta do anything.
We are getting ready to put a record out
and tomorrow we're taping a live show
for radio station and then Wednesday
we're taping a song for Conan.
Oh beautiful.
And then so just a little quick,
quick trip out,
get to get to finally get the new band
at a rehearsal space and see what's
going on though.
I'm excited.
Nice.
That's fun.
Last time I went with you to Conan,
I never.
Yeah,
it was fun man.
You know those tv things as they go.
It's always a strange dynamic,
you know,
even even for performance because you
get there and you do it and you wait and
you do it again for tv and you know and
you need to do it and you wait.
You wait and wait.
But if all of the ones that we played,
I think that one,
and maybe it's just because it's in
California,
where there's a far more mellow,
laid back vibe.
I think Cohen has a really nice studio
spaces bigger,
louder than New York.
Was it still fun with her older,
more tight buildings and the union crews
are on it,
you know,
they're running a crack tight,
um,
which may be a better thing to keep your
adrenaline up.
Oh yeah.
We sat around all day and then at 4:30
like,
okay,
you're on a two minutes,
you know,
by the way millions of people are going
to watch this.
Like,
so when is this going to be on a that
I'm not sure we're taping it because
we're out here for the other thing as
opposed to waiting until the fall when
we're actually her on tour.
So it was bringing everybody out and
we've done it twice.
But yeah,
him and Andy,
they'd been great to us,
man.
No,
they're awesome man.
He's a great guy.
He's a well known,
nice guy.
Really.
Can you tell?
He's doing a show,
sees a genuine music lover to listen.
Man has always been fun.
We've got to do this more often.
Fuck and startle Sampson.
Apparently.
I'll be coming here every once in a
while.
Alright,
ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back tomorrow with Kevin rose.
See you that later.
Oh yeah.